pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui chers ennemis bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde au nom au maire
d' bienvenus ouais je sais bâton pied
alors bienvenue sur le plateau bon bien
asseyez-vous bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde en parle
l'émission avec nous ce soir aux lyxor
[Applaudissements]
albert dupontel
les beckham là
en fait
[Applaudissements]
jean michel cousteau
est chaplin
edouard lipa
[Applaudissements]
pascal
m
mais blind test or le blanc
le gala on a vu
[Applaudissements]
c'est à toi thierry qui l'a acheté en
faisant un don à l'association laurette
fugain
ah oui c'est vrai il a téléphoné il m'a
dit est ce que je peux investir mille
euros pour toi à la vente aux enchères
de l'association laurette fugain et
qu'est-ce qui me rapporte pour 1000
euros mais ça vaut plus que ça la
charmante c'est le costume de scène de
michel sardou costumes de scène de
michel sardou
c'est sûr que c'est bien quand on voit
la taille des jambes n'y a pas de doute
c'est un certificat d'authenticité avec
salvador at-elle chapeau d'henri
salvador toi je suis très fier et j'ai
vendu mes clefs de bagnole à claude
berri comme quoi il a prononcé sa leur
ont fait le tour des ventes aux enchères
mais comme il n'a pas trop de blé
évidemment c'est ses potes qui paye
aussi qu'est ce que tu veux que je fous
du costume de scène je veux que tu
mettes l'adresse de l'association
laurette fugain en bas de ce qu'il vous
plaît monsieur galfond
voilà un que tu m'aides ça en vente au
profit de l'association laurette fugain
coeur donc je le revends moi je l'achète
1000 euros et une vente jon davies ardo
donc si vous voulez acheter
pour combien bon mais pendant 1heure
cher on le met aux enchères voilà le
costume de scène de michel sardou
ça devrait faire dans les dix mille
saint louis à wayne ont bien je vais le
garder comme ça toute la soirée je sais
bien que c'est bien
laurent et la statue que tarak ben ammar
a acheté dix mille euros
je pense qu'il n'ya pas d'enchère donc
on va lui adjugé à la statue au profit
de l'abbé pierre de france voilà donc
tard axa étudiants nés pour 10000 si tu
veux venir chercher la semaine prochaine
s'il veut mettre plus si peu à peu un
oui mais ça dépend je sais pas comment
marche le film la passion de jésus
christ va bien très bien donc il peut
mettre dix mille de plus caraquet le
bienvenu à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
tous
j'accueille maintenant en dessous luxe
[Musique]
un juif bonsoir bonsoir alors on parle
français ou anglais
vous pouvez poser les questions en
français gérard pont près en anglais
d'accord on à faire des vannes en
italien ses deux fils et les professeurs
de littérature française vous parler
français avec lui de temps en temps
alors le monde entier a parlé de vous
vous êtes mondialement célèbre hans blix
puisque vous étiez le chef des
inspecteurs en désarmement de l'onu en
irak entre 2000 et 2003 vous et vos
collaborateurs étaient chargés de
trouver ces fameuses armes de
destruction massive de saddam hussein
alors vous témoigner aujourd'hui dans un
livre publié chez fayard et qui
s'intitule irak les armes
introuvable et vous avez choisi merci
tout le monde en parle pour en parler
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais vous nous présenter
rapidement vous êtes suédois vous êtes
né en 1928 vous fait quand même 76 ans
plutôt solides les suédois assa concert
vous êtes né à oops allah vous avez une
carrière de diplomate jusqu'en 1997 et
fin 1999 vous êtes en patagonie avec
votre épouse qui est diplomate également
pour échapper aux impôts rappelons le
nom parce que son épouse eva kit est
chargé des régions antarctique
donc il était parti là-bas tous les deux
c'est ça voilà voilà donc vous êtes en
patagonie avec votre épouse quand on
vous avertit qu'un certain monsieur
koffi c'est un monsieur café cherche à
vous joindre évidemment c'est kofi annan
qui vous propose le poste de inspecteur
en chef pour l'irak
alors vous vous êtes contents et à la
retraite et à stockholm avec votre femme
vous lui dites non dans un premier temps
oui parce que j'étais bien avec ma femme
nous avons fait des excursions
oui d'un seul coup ça vous retombe sur
la tête vous dites voir plein de merde
et vous vous dites non tu tournes en
antarctique
mais au bout du compte j'ai fini par
accepter cette proposition qu en mars
2000 vous vous retrouvez à new york dans
l'immeuble de l'onu dans votre bureau du
51e étage et trois ans plus tard un
dimanche le 16 mars 2003 toujours dans
ce petit bureau du 51e étage en slicks
vous comprenez que c'est fini les
inspecteurs rentrer les états unis ont
passé outre l'opposition du conseil de
sécurité
vous êtes dans lequel est à ce moment là
quand vous voyez que finalement tout
votre action s'est soldée par un échec
puisque c'est la guerre j'étais déçu
parce que je pensais que quelques mois
de plus d'inspections aurait permis de
montrer que tous ces sites
les sites dont
les états unis et les britanniques et
leurs agences de renseignements disait
qu'il contenait des armes de destruction
massive aurait fait l'objet
d'inspections et on n'aurait pas trouvé
et ça aurait montré au monde ainsi
qu'aux grands pouvoirs et aux grandes
puissances que la preuve dont il dispose
et est inadéquate
voilà il faut dire aussi qu'avec trois
cent mille hommes massés dans le désert
et l'arrivée de la saison chaude
la guerre était peut-être inévitable
chaque les américains n'avaient pas
attaqué à ce moment là après ça il
fallait attendre 6 mois non oui c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque il y avait de moins
en moins de chances d'aboutir à une
solution pacifique on avait pratiquement
300 mille hommes qui attendaient dans le
désert peut-être aurait-on pu l'éviter
si quelque chose de spectaculaire
s'était produit c'est saddam hussein
avait prononcé un discours s'il avait
promis que dans les dix jours à venir il
aurait résolu les différentes questions
qui se posaient mais ça ne s'est pas
passé ainsi et les américains se
pénétrer et les inspecteurs sont partis
voilà alors on ira que les soldats
américains évidemment on ne trouve pas
plus d'armes de destruction massive que
vous 1
il y en avait pas le fameux moment de
vérité dont par les bouchers peau elle
n'a pas eu lieu ce qui démontre
l'ampleur du mensonge parce que
finalement personne n'a trouvé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on n'a toujours pas trouvé
d'armes de destruction massive en irak
il avait dit avant l'arrivée de la
guerre que c'était le moment de la
vérité
ce serait le déclenchement de la guerre
et à ce moment là on démontrerait qu'il
y avait désarmé en fait la réalité était
que ce moment de vérité a montré qu'il
n'y en avait pas
est ce que pour vous tony blair et
george bush sont des menteurs ou des
illuminés je pense qu'ils ont induit le
monde en erreur mais je ne pense pas
qu'ils l'ont fait délibérément et je ne
dirai jamais qu'ils ont été des menteurs
il n'y a aucune preuve
indiquant qu'il savait que ce qu'il
disait était erronée au contraire
nombreux sont les conversations que j'ai
eues avec tony blair new j'avais le
sentiment qu'il était véritablement
convaincu mais une conviction un petit
peu comme celle des gens des siècles
passés en europe qui pensaient qu'il y
avait des sorcières
il était cent pour cent sûr qu'il y
avait des sorcières et tous que la
question des preuves il la traitait un
peu à la légère c'est le voyait un chat
noir loin ongles d'une rue disait que
c'était la preuve qu'il ya des sorcières
donc des illuminés donc des gens
finalement parlé du diable en parlant de
saddam hussein qui comme les islamistes
parle du grand satan en parlant des
américains une certaine façon en scène
s'était comporté d'une manière qui
correspondent à cette description
mais malgré tout je crois que ce qui est
important c'est que de tout temps dans
la société il faut exercer le sens
critique et si l'on perd l'exercice du
sens critique on perd la science on perd
un bon ordre social aussi il ne faut
jamais croire en les sorcières la
superstition est mauvaise et les
inspecteurs il essaye d'établir des
faits c'est leur mission et moi aussi
à l'automne 2002 je croyais qu'il y
avait des armes de destruction massive
mais les résultats des inspections les
faits ont montré que ce n'était pas le
cas
j'avais des doutes et en mars les
preuves étaient très faibles et en mai
nous étions pratiquement persuadé qu'il
n'y en avait pas alors en revanche blix
le président chirac vous a séduit par sa
sagesse quand vous l'avez vu vous a dit
il n'y a pas de preuves sérieuses
il a dit la guerre et la série séduit
n'est pas persuadé persuadé non mais
c'est vrai il vous dit ils nous l'ont
intérêts il vous dira pas de toi viens
pas de preuves sérieuses la guerre est
la pire de toutes les solutions en
intervenant là bas les américains vont
ouvrir la boîte de pandore dont
finalement vous avez trouvé chez jacques
chirac quelqu'un de très sage je crois
qu'il était réaliste
tout d'abord il était convaincu qu'il
n'y avait pas d'armes et
et on second lieu il estimait que les
agences de renseignement et thèse qu'il
a appelé des agences qui s'intoxiquent
l'une l'autre et il était très préoccupé
également par l'évolution de la
situation au proche orient si l'on
devait entrer en guerre et il avait
raison
est ce que vous avez parlé de chirac
avec bush et blair
non non mais c'est bon j'ai vu monsieur
douche avant de voir monsieur chirac je
le vis en octobre 2002 puis monsieur
chirac en janvier 2003 croyez pas aux
brics que washington avait décidé en
fait la guerre depuis longtemps depuis
août 2002 et que les inspections que
vous dirigiez était uniquement destiné à
donner à l'armée américaine le temps de
se préparer au combat
lorsque l'on parle de la décision prise
par les américains il faut penser est
président il s'agit bien du président
ils étaient nombreux au ministère de la
défense américain où l'on pensait que en
fait il n'y avait pas vraiment de se
déchaîner et du mail à la vie d'ailleurs
mais c'est le président qui prend la
décision et je crois qu'en 2002 n'avait
pas encore pris cette décision
ce n'est qu'en septembre je crois qu'il
a décidé qu'on adopterait une approche
multilatérale avec les nations unies
peut être que c'était la limite
extérieure ultime et il pensait aller on
va les laisser faire et on verra si ça
marche mais je ne pense pas que la
décision de tuer la prendre avant plus
tard
quel a été le comportement des irakiens
durant une inspection est ce qu'il avait
vraiment envie de tout montrer une
grande différence entre le comportement
des irakiens à notre encontre et à
l'encontre des autres inspecteurs des
inspections d'avant parce que il était
très ouvert c'est à dire qu'ils ou près
tous les sites y compris les palais de
saddam hussein qui s'est ouvert il ne
serait pas comme moi sur le fond il
pesait 12 millions pages de documents de
déclaration qu'il nous fournissait pas
beaucoup d'informations est-ce qu'ils
ont caché des armes en syrie n'a pas
caché en séries on en aurait eu des
preuves
les l'armée américaine estime que ça
n'est pas le cas et les syriens je pense
n'aurait pas beaucoup aimé en avoir
pendant la recherche des armes de
destruction massive
avant la guerre j'avais été victime de
pressions notamment dick cheney qui vous
fait comprendre que si vos inspecteurs
ne trouve pas rapidement des armes de
destruction massive et vous pourriez
discréditer quand même il n'a pas dit
rapidement ce qu'il a dit qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à jeter le discrédit
sur les inspecteurs en faveur du
désarmement
donc moi m'a semblé comprendre que cela
voulait dire que le désarmement c'était
quelque chose d'important pour lui c'est
des inspecteurs pouvait-il faire revenir
tant mieux sinon ce serait eux mêmes
qu'ils le feraient alors quelques mois
plus tard toujours pas d'armes de
destruction massive bush et blair pour
convaincre leurs opinions publiques
disent avoir des preuves flagrantes et
vous vous surprenez à vous interroger
sur ses preuves
lorsqu'elles sont produites par coline
powell notamment des bandes magnétiques
il fait entendre et au moment où vous
les écoutez vous vous dites mais d'où ça
sort l'objectif de la présentation des
preuves pas que l'étoile était de
convaincre l'opinion publique américaine
de la présence d'armes de destruction
massive moi j'ai effectivement assisté
cet exposé j'avais un peu l'impression
d'être au tribunal avec un précurseur
qui présente ses preuves
lorsque le procureur le serait il faut
qu'il y ait un contre interrogatoire
je suis allé voir mes experts et je leur
ai posé la question peut penser et les
commentaires étaient plutôt critiquée
par conséquent j'ai décidé que c'était à
moi d'aller au conseil de sécurité pour
leur dire que nous ne tuons pas
impressionner par ses preuves
oui alors ses preuves flagrantes on n'a
plus jamais entendu parler depuis de
toute façon n'ont vu de nombreux
exemples d'autres preuves
elle consiste à dire qu'il ya des sites
avec des armes chimiques on avait vu des
camions de décontamination or nos
inspecteurs s'étaient rendus sur ce site
il avait pris des échantillons sur place
et il n'avait vu aucun signe de présence
d'armes biologiques chimiques et les
camions qu'on y avait vu des camions de
transport d'eau donc c'était vraiment
une grosse intox ou alors à ce moment-là
la campagne contre vous ce excellèrent
on vous conseille d'aller chez
l'opticien pour voir les preuves
flagrantes
vous êtes cloué au pilori présenté comme
un imbécile et comme un caniche français
c'était dur pour vous à ce moment là non
dit tu crois que tu es un chien de garde
mais en fait tu n'es jamais qu'un petit
caniche je trouvais ça plutôt drôle
je n'ai pas apprécié le conseil de
sécurité c'était mon patron et le
conseil de sécurité respectez les
inspecte aucun problème
rien de méchant alors pourtant même qu
une poële à l'époque aller batailler
pour avoir des preuves plus convaincante
et laisser ya n'avait pas été en mesure
de les lui donner
yacine qui je crois que s'il avait
rejeter toute une série d'affaires qui
lui avait présentée c'est qu'il avait
gardé ce qu'il considérait comme étant
le meilleur enseignement mais il ya
quelques jours à berne il a dit c'est
effectivement pour un de ces cas
d'autres le camion devant transporter
censé transporter des armes biologiques
que c'était une erreur et il a dit qu'il
n'aurait pas présenté ses cages il avait
su et je trouve que c'est honnête de le
dire maintenant qui a fabriqué ces
fossés la cia et le fbi l'agent de
renseignement de confiance
de nombreux transfuges peut-être un peu
trop un transfuge tirage que ça ne les
intéressait pas beaucoup qu'il y à des
inspecteurs ce qu'ils voulaient c'est
qu'on libère le pays et le semis sont
parvenus
hans blix est ce que vous pouvez dire ce
soir que les états unis ont envahi
l'irak enfants dans leurs interventions
sur des faux ont envahi l'irak où se
tenait sur l'argument vertu duquel il y
avait des armes de destruction massive
et un danger immédiat
l'avenant or il aurait dû savoir que les
preuves étaient trop faibles
on s'est aperçu qu'il n'y avait pas
d'armes de destruction massive si il
avait dit ils ont envahi l'irak pour se
débarrasser d'un affreux dictateur et
d'un régime sanguinaire
ça aurait été prêt mais il ne devrait
pas pu persuader le congrès américain
est clair n'aurait pas pu persuader le
parlement britannique
talleyrand guerre pour mettre fin à
cette dictature
peut-être qu'à l'avenir et dans l'avenir
des nations unies et des états unis nous
sommes prêts à mettre fin aux dictatures
simplement parce que les sanguinaires et
affreuse mais a pour l'instant non
peut-être que le jour viendra et en tout
cas c'est le souhait que je forme orale
et alors
après un an après cette guerre c'est le
bourbier irakien
est-ce que vous pensez que les états
unis sont partis dans une aventure
comparable à celle du vietnam
hans blix il ya de grandes différences
entre les deux certes ils sont dans un
bourbier comme vous le dit très
justement mais pour l'instant il est
très difficile de savoir dans quel sens
les choses évoluent au vietnam
il essayait d'apporter leur appui à un
gouvernement qui ne bénéficiait pas de
l'appui du peuple
or ici les états unis essaient d'établir
un régime qui aurait et bénéficierait de
l'appui de la population ça paraît très
difficile et c'est vrai qu'ils sont dans
une situation dont je ne dirais pas que
c'est le chaos
mais c'est certainement une situation
très difficile
vous pourrez qu'ils vont envoyer des
renforts là bas on parle de 500 mille
hommes sur place vous pensez qu'ils vont
le faire
c'est beaucoup mais plus que maintenant
est ce que vous croyez que le transfert
de souveraineté pourrait se faire comme
prévu au 30 juin 2004 les dirigeants
politiques américains aussi en doute
mais il faut se poser la question qu'est
ce qu'un transfert de souveraineté s'il
ya encore l'armée américaine sur place
qui maîtrise le pays
est ce que vous croyez que cette
histoire peut coûter la présidence de
george bush le cas ça aura en tout cas
une influence en octobre était que ça
lui coûte la présidence je crois que
tous les politiques doivent payer
lorsqu'ils sont des choses qui ne sont
pas tout à fait sincère je crois qu'ils
ont vraiment manipuler un peu la
formation c'est vraiment l'art de la
persuasion ans élite se sont livrés
c'est une vision un petit peu biaisé
donc ça n'est pas du mensonge je me
savais pas tout à fait la vérité non
c'est qu'il est bien pour le monde que
bush s'en aille
vous personnellement d'avoir une
politique étrangère qui serait nettement
plus mainstream américaine bush mépriser
les nations unies et il préférait y
aller seul plutôt que de demander à
leurs alliés de les aider mais il ne
pouvait pas en fait le faire seul par le
passé les états unis ont été un bon
leader ils ont essayé de créer de
renforcer la communauté internationale
d'organiser les nations unies qui est
loin d'être une organisation parfaite
qui a beaucoup de faiblesses mais c'est
la seule que nous avons donc il faut la
réparer et non pas l'ignorer justement
est ce que voudrait que les nations
unies peuvent faire encore quelque chose
pour l'irak
oui parce que les nations unies sont un
symbole de légitimité et les irakiens ne
veulent pas être sous la tutelle d'un
pouvoir d'occupation pour les allemands
quand le japon ça a fonctionné mais pas
pour l'irak
ils se sentent humiliés et je crois que
les nations unies pourraient les aider à
ne plus se sentir humilié
pour l'instant je ne sais pas très bien
comment mais peut-être et j'espère en
tout cas que ce sera le cas merci hans
blix les arnaques
c'est d'éviter ces fayard
juste une dernière question en slicks
les armes de destruction massive vous
avez cherché sous le lit non
[Rires]
[Musique]
et maintenant en dissociant père
[Applaudissements]
c'est super
voici albert dupontel
[Musique]
à lui avant soir vous avez vu une
interview de hans blix là c'est étonnant
quand même
guy oui bah oui avait pas de preuve les
mecs nous ont complètement manipulé ça
s'appelle se [ __ ] de la gueule du
monde
voilà entier voilà georges marchais
talents culinaires des mots et voilà
antisociale de l'état
[Musique]
un message de georges pour dire toi même
alors albert dupontel acteurs haute
réalisateur aujourd'hui c'est l'acteur
que nous recevons pour un film de
nicolas boukhrief qui s'appelle le
convoyeur avec jean dujardin françois
berléand vous sorti le 14 avril
c'est le troisième film de nicolas
boukhrief et le film se passe dans une
société de convoyage de fonds
c'est la première fois et c'est bizarre
ni les français ni les américains ni
personne n'avait pensé à ça avant alors
c'est marrant c'est qu'on voyait ans et
des ouvriers en fait en gagnant
oui enfin c'est bizarre c'est les mecs
qui gagnent un salaire de misère pour
transporter des millions mais ça fait
partie de leur vie
oui ça fait partie des aberrations de la
société voilà actuel de la même façon
qu'il ya un président des etats-unis qui
dit que les armes n'existe pas il ya on
donne 1000 euros par mois des ti pour
transporter des millions d'euros dans
des fourgons c'est un peu un peu
aberrant app-ps au critt un peu faux cul
un peu anti sociale comme vous dites oui
antisociales c'est très bien documenté
une enquête qui a été fait par par une
journaliste avant tout est vrai dans
lequel pas tout tout tout maison pas
démenti la globalité
alors voilà c'est un film qui était un
suspense sur un fond sociétal
on pourrait dire j'en voulais parler que
dans les bois là il a pas les émissions
culturelles associées table très bien si
c'est un film noir un film de genre qui
rencontre la vie d'un groupe
emblématique de la société actuelle
voilà c'est de penser les mec paumé qui
sont armés avec une tentation permanente
évidemment depuis que le fric qu'ils
transportent
ouais ouais c'est un petit peu ça quand
même un paradoxe effectivement alors au
début votre personnage alexandre se fait
engager par cette petite société de
transport de fonds
les affaires vont pas bien on parle de
vente bilan
dépôt de bilan vente aux américains donc
un certain stress d'entreprise
effectivement qui doublées d'un stress
et dès qu'ils sortent du fourgon ils
peuvent faire de leur vie et au travail
peuvent perdre leur boulot ça fait
beaucoup quand même
alors en plus cette petite société est
victime de deux braquages répétés alors
on se demande s'il n'ya pas une
complicité entre les convoyeurs et les
truands qui l'est qui les attaquent et
on se demande qui vous êtes au départ on
vous voit arriver alors on this impôts
mais qui a trouvé un boulot il fait ça
parce qu'il sait pas quoi faire d'autre
ensuite on pense que vous êtes un flic
peut-être qui est en train de l'infiltré
la société pour savoir qui organise ces
braquages
on pensait peut-être vous est d'ailleurs
un braqueur évidemment je vais pas vous
dire
espérant conjoncture c'est une des
forces du film c'est vrai qu'à 45
minutes on sait pas ce qui se passe ni
ce qu'il vient faire
ouais et pourtant présent son fauteuil
et vous 45 minutes quand le mobile
apparaît du monsieur je le trouve très
touchant très émouvant et très fort
voilà est-ce que vous pourriez dire en
regardant votre caméra magnéto serge
magnéto serge savard le texte est pas
compliqué
on est mariés les enfants l'appellent
garde à la meule est désintéressé dans
psychiatrique moitié qui toi je suis
rouge c'est ton d'armes respectent la
salut moi c'est jacky les nouveaux
appartements mais c'est la momie
tiens c'est pas compliqué son charme
battant des charges
petit bois celle où avant qui travaille
dans une banque doivent être changées
dis moi tu t'es déjà fait braquer mois
c'est un jeu du chargement imagine jda
cette histoire de se sentir moins qu'on
en ait trois haltes à grain donc j'ai
connu neuf gars y laisse pas un témoin
mais moi je dis que c'est mmc ou du
cochon
des itinéraires qui sont plus
dangereuses qu'est ce que vous faites là
aux nationalistes pour créer 20 je vais
demander à ce que j'ai des personnes
dans ma chambre
tu es là pour l'adrénaline sa peau
voilà le convoyeur le mythe de la
boukhrief avec un beurre du pantone est
notre invité ce soir
alors le personnage c'est un personnage
comme c'est un très costaud très musclé
on voit faire de la gym et tout en même
temps d'une grande fragilité en toujours
l'impression qui va partir quoi ce deal
et nicolas maîtresse est assez joli
c'est habile scénaristiquement et au
niveau du cinéma c'est de dire on va
montrer la force plutôt que de la voir
la jouer comme ça on va garder le jeu
pour l'émotion la maladresse le
pathétique le ridicule d'un grotesque le
pato est ce que tout ce personnage
véhicule un peu comme le dr saxe dans un
autre registre un peu comme dampierre
d'irréversible voilà c'est des registres
que j'aime bien ouais alors on souffre
quand il fait de la muscu mais on
souffre encore plus quand on croise son
regard quoi est quelque chose qui se
dégage de lui qui est assez pathétique
d'ailleurs puisque quand on vous voilà
vous avez l'aï allumé malicieux mais
dans le film vous êtes vraiment des cons
paye tout est possible j'étais bien payé
il ya du jardin aussi jean dujardin qui
est excellent c'est pas du tout j'ai pas
la télé d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas la
télé non c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
ces chargements jamais venu si j'avais
eu les missions avant non mais il ya
jean dujardin je connaissais pas et qui
est très sympathique berléand
exceptionnel voire me connaissait par
ailleurs claude perron que je
connaissais sans avoir la télévision et
nicolas marié qui joue également dans le
dernier d'un créateur et une flopée
d'autres acteurs vraiment formidable
quoi une grande réussite de boukhrief
que je salue le personnage est
éminemment doux et sympathique intègre
authentique voilà très bien on
l'applaudît
ça sort le 14 avril alors j'ai mis
antisocial tout à l'heure ce qui est
quand même assez anti social vous en
convenez non vous avez été renvoyée
d'école maternelle à 4 ans nerfs c'est
quand même pas mal non fêter des
archives
c'est assez c'est vrai le pire c'est
vrai et ensuite vous étiez à l'école
paul bert à conflans et on était obligé
de vous mettre du chatterton sur la
bouche pour vous clouer le bec par vous
renseigne non mais vous rendez compte
format blu ray plusieurs c'est le sait
exactement cinq ans et un fumier
d'instituteurs certainement pédophiles
mais à l'époque c'était motorisés
qu'aujourd'hui qui m'a foutu du chef
cartonne sur l'écran quand j'avais voulu
brûler sa maison
non là c'est encore ont quand même je
sais pas si j'étais si vous voulez faire
pire est que ce film et je savais où il
habitait et acheter des glaces a
clairement quelle adresse
j'ai sans portable j'ai tout et je me
rappelle qu'il avait une coccinelle à
plusieurs fois j'aurais bien vu cette
coccinelle partir en fumée
voilà sans façon walt disney sociale
voilà la seule chose qui arrive à vos
calmés un peu c'est la gym ouaip il ya
pas que ça ait des parents gentil
surtout qu'ils m'ont un peu calmé un peu
dirigé la drogue la drogue assez tôt et
voilà une relation incestueuse on peut y
aller et puis non je faisais beaucoup de
sport et un petit mois j'étais assez
assez agitée de l'essence ce qui vous
calme est plutôt c'était le cinéma vous
passiez votre vie enfermée dans les
salles ça je fuyais la réalité comme
vous je sais pas comment vous l'avez
fait q vous n'avez fut la réalité
certainement aussi puisqu'on y est même
un vision vous continuez au cinéma c'est
encore pire
voilà il y avait ainsi des mots bout de
la rue s'appelle le palace alors alors
j'allais vraiment papa qui était docteur
à la même rue et je disais j'ai besoin
d'argent pour acheter des fournitures
scolaires ça se terminait par un lié à
10 15 ou 20 francs à vous rentriez à
deux heures de l'après midi vous sortie
à minuit il faut un peu de temps enfin
jeunes gens rentraient plus tôt et puis
un peu plus vieux l'antenne gens
retraités tous est d'eric rohmer achats
sont d'ailleurs j'avais c'était la
synergie pas de la cinéphilie
alors ensuite vous suivez l'orientation
paternelle pour devenir médecin en fait
qu'à 35 de demain
si jusqu'au jour où aux urgences albert
dupontel vous voyez débarquer à un mec
de 20 balais complètement bousillé par
un accident de moto et là vous vous
dites il faut vivre quoi il faut faire
ce qu'on a envie de faire dans la vie
parce que finalement ça tire à rien quoi
en fait j'ai été un peu aidés ont mis à
pied pour un stage tout le monde était
soulager les malades comme les médecins
que je m'en aille 1 c'est vrai j'avais
été très frappé par six mois du rejoint
exactement à l'hôpital beaujon à clichy
c'est franchement la nuit vous imaginez
pas ce qui se passe que j'ai été très
frappée je me dis si vivre c'est avoir
des émotions autant se dépêcher des
soins parce que c'est assez aléatoire
voilà là vous vous inscrivez à un cours
de théâtre et puis après ben voilà on
connaît la suite il ya eu d'abord le one
man show qui était extraordinaire c'est
à dire il fait des sketches comme le bac
français comme rambo et c'est un truc
que j'ai pas compris qu'ils avaient un
tel succès quand vous avez commencé à
faire des sketchs bien je vous ai dit
non ce que je fais c'est du cinéma
et vous savez je vais toujours faire du
cinéma mais le spectacle a été la
poterne qui m'a permis de rentrer dans
la forteresse du showbiz c'est une sorte
de cri primal mais je trouvais ça pauvre
et frustre un que je voulais faire du
cinoche bernie la bande dessinée du
spectacle créateur la banque
cinémathèque le prochain l'enfermer
dehors sera toujours un spectacle voilà
il ya eu dernier évidemment le créateur
ensuite l'acteur avec des films aussi
important que la maladie de sachs que
deux villes alors vous êtes très
lonesome cowboy un vous vous êtes très
anti société du spectacle digne de
compte à rendre à personne je vis comme
gandhi
je n'ai besoin de rien on ne peut pas
m'avoir le vrai luxe dans ce métier
c'est la liberté de dire non ou de dire
oui je suis aussi franck bush
non c'est vrai vous je suis un peu
discret voilà ça suffit d'être
marginalisés pourquoi pas mais je suis
un peu discret c'est tout je suis pas je
suis pas hystérique avec les médias
j'avais failli être un peu les gens à la
télé ça la culture l'ennui la télé comme
ça vous êtes une agressivité je vais
agressive et c'est vrai que moi j'ai pas
la télé depuis dix ans je m'en passe
très bien et heureusement je n'ai pas je
veux beaucoup de films j'ai 800 dvd
milka cette gym etc
et voilà et la télé qu'on arrache à
l'automne j'ai rien à faire je la
regardais ces foules chose d'une chose
inutile à part votre émission mal de
choses inutiles qu'on peut voir non mais
je mange avec cette évolution
non non mais là je pense que cette
émission est utile il ya 2 3 millions
d'indiens qui vient non mais souvent ya
un procès par exemple enfin se relâche
pas mais on nous a fait un gros procès
et sur bernie sur la violence au cinéma
et sur les rails à bercy je n'en parle
pas à ce film là d'ailleurs est interdit
aux moins de 12 ans vient de baptiser
donc il pas si loin que ça l'autre fois
je suis malade donc j'ai pas la télé
mais la violence au cinéma c'est un faux
procès ce que le cinéma est un lieu
protégé sérieuse de polémiques
d'expression de débat mais ses protégés
on rentre dans une salle de cinéma au
hasard le même quotidien variés
facilement famille c'est franchement et
ses goûts et ses consommateurs crétins
tant pis pour lui parcours la télévision
rend dans la chambre d'hôtel craque on
appuie sur le bouton je tombais sur elle
si la semaine dernière les mecs qui
brûlait dans la jeep les américains
dépecer par la foule j'étais très
choquée parce que j'étais pas prêt à ça
ouais donc une perversité eux se cache
derrière l'alibi de l'information entre
alibi de l'information et voyeurisme il
ya un truc une frontière qui
franchissent allègrement donc le procès
de la violence au cinéma
montcuq quoi ça n'existe pas assez c'est
le mec qui va au cinéma voir un film
c'est ce qui va voir sauf si c'est un
combat sort s'est testé la tv comme ça
non mais je n'aime pas ce qu'elle me
fais pas mon temps voilà sauf quand je
suis là bien sûr c'est pas une attitude
un peu snob c'est un nom écoutez
franchement d'abord elle est
involontaire c'est un jour un jour m'a
coupé cas parce que je payais pas donc
au départ je vais voir laphil je me suis
rendu compte que je passais que je mens
pas ça très bien
bush non mais c'est pas un peu snob ne
pas payer le câble
bien c'est ce que je vais vous faire
maintenant
non non non et à prendre un pain mais
l'interview un parmi d'autres
[Musique]
j'ai déjà l'émission objection pardon
j'avais déjà vu cette émission une fois
d'ailleurs j'ai été très choquée c'est
j'avais presque envie de venir en
courant c'était quand il y avait un
philosophe parisien type closerie des
lilas qui s'appelait finkielkraut oui
c'est ça c'est un an qui ressemble car
yvan attal qui expliquait en gros que
les palestiniens il cette étape
désespérée mais qu'ils avaient le
désespoir pas très poli puisqu'il ne lui
faire sauter chez les gens j'ai trouvé
ça totalement indécent elle était
tellement grossier et malvoyants qu'il a
réussi à faire pleurer le délicieux et
juliette binoche
moi je vous soumets m'a profondément
choqué j'ai presque en visite en
bretagne de prendre la voiture et
d'intervenir sur le plateau et dire
voilà parce que quand on en arrive à se
faire sauter avec des cartouches de
dynamite c'est qu'on est franchement
désespéré voilà il n'y a pas de
politesse ou pas avoir des espoirs donc
[Applaudissements]
cette émission d'intérêt
heureusement que t'as pas la télé sites
en bretagne c'est pas prendre la bagnole
de faire 500 banques pour mettre un
bourre-pif un mec est une connerie
ouais imaginons serait pas tranquille en
garde à vue alors un parmi d'autres donc
si vous étiez un des sept péchés
capitaux vous seriez lequel la luxure je
ferai plus souvent la télévision via
parce que si vous étiez un des dix
commandements tu ne tueras point comme
ça je n'hésiterai pas un des sept nains
simple est comme ça je pourrais me
présenter à la campagne présidentielle
américaine
il ya du grand show en toi aussi si vous
étiez en décembre elle maintient le
dernier le 101e pour est le chouchou est
une des sept merveilles du monde
les jardins suspendus de babylone qui
aujourd'hui se trouve à bagdad comme ça
je ferai du jardinage avec interdiction
pour les chars de marché sur la pelouse
un bravo
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez un des cinq sens l'odorat
pour m'autodétruire lors de la promotion
de mes films je vous étiez un des sept
arts le cinéma pour apprendre quelques
trucs un des quatre points cardinaux du
sud pour pouvoir perdre le nord en
permanence en bravo si vous étiez un les
trois mousquetaires d'artagnan pour
piquer les ferrer la reine plutôt que de
lui rendre sa couronne
voilà est un des sept mercenaires du
brenner pour avoir une coupe de cheveux
toujours à la mode ça vous étiez albert
dupontel un des douze travaux d'hercule
les écuries d'augias en faisant passer
le fleuve par matignon l'elysée
l'assemblée nationale l'a si vous étiez
un des 31 jours du mois le premier
pendant les vacances et dernier pendant
que je travaille si vous étiez à 17
jours de la semaine le lundi parce que
tout est encore possible et un des cinq
continents l'afrique pour me venger
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant g
merci selinger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez pas la télé winslet jodie du
coup comme hélas pas la terre séverine
ferrer qui présente le 20 heures sur
france 3 depuis une semaine de plaine
voka d'estonie relâche très bien tu très
heureuse en tout cas c'est tombé dans la
vie fait suite à la serre des déserts
j'ai toujours trouvé intrigant donc tu
vas passer d'un très grand mais s'est
bien passé donc tricot inconvenant
attention alors c'est vrai une ferrer
donc fan2 comme ça vous regarde aurait
maintenant sur m6 le samedi à 11h45
mais en plus les fringues puisque vous
avez une ligne de vêtements séverine la
femme enceinte pour la femme enceinte
longtemps et c'est pas du séverine
ferrer non voilà ça s'appelle miss maman
vous êtes obligés de faire des enfants
pour promouvoir votre votre ligne ou non
la preuve que non sinon vu que j'avais
une obligation
et voilà je les réalise et nous publier
un livre qui s'appelle des étoiles plein
la tête chez robert laffont c'est votre
autobiographie et je n'arrive conseil
albert est un disque un album qui sort
le 27 avril
en attendant il ya un single qui
s'appelle dieu me pardonne et un parfum
non ça c'était il ya quelques jours
non
[Applaudissements]
je
tél
m
ma foi
il n'y a pas de film en crypté avant non
non non non je croyais l a pas fait de
films en tout et n'importe quoi sans
qu'il est très accroché là il est chaud
est mort des deux fermes à noter si tu
pantel fait notre magnéto serge c'est
bien je m'arrete mans et je suis très
fidèle
non c'est vrai regardez toujours compter
un peu intéressé il a dit magnéto serge
serge magnéto serge manif mais on s'est
rachetés ou est ce qu'on dit ça
[Musique]
non
dieu me pardonne série
extrait de l'album qui s'appelle
séverine terreur sortie le 27 avril je
me tenais les toits oui mais le prix est
scandalisé par l'obligation ça m'a un
peu moustier ce qu'il faut de toute
façon il n'y a aucune chance alors mais
voilà battu résigné je n'ai je pas dans
ma campagne j'ai regardé son merci
infiniment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime ce genre de mec ou ça te fait
peur toi je suis intrigué je demande
qu'à connaître
ouais tu demande qu'à connaître à lui
n'ont visiblement pas visiblement non
mais je crois que personnel service
enfin axway
il m'a dit je respecte la [ __ ] tiens
je te retrouver sa part eu un problème
non mais c'est pas c'est pas votre votre
type de mec vous le trouvez un peu trop
fou j'aime bien les hommes plus âgés que
moi c'est déjà pour nous c'est déjà pas
mal
donc non je c'est pas mon fils de m je
demande qu'elle connaître moi ça va avec
fred alors tout va très bien
bien leur en revient au livre qui
s'appelle des étoiles plein la tête
publié chez robert laffont
alors voilà vous raconter votre vie la
réunion avec vos parents blanche et eric
blanche employé dans un salon de
coiffure et ricky fait des petits
boulots
on n'a jamais très bien su ce qui
faisait votre père quand même ça fait il
a été représentant il était coiffeur ils
représentent 1 et coiffeurs ça veut dire
que les bisexuels ou pas du tout pas du
tout ok on n'a pas parlé mais je ne
crois pas ça a été vraiment une très
belle éducation je suis très contente
j'avais pape à la maison et maman qui
travaillaient mais c'était vraiment une
enfance très équilibré pourquoi pas dans
le sens inverse tout va bien alors
blanche votre mère tombe enceinte et
hélas ils partent à montpellier où vous
naissez heureusement et là c'est le
drame
non c'est non justement c'est très
touchant oui c'est très difficile bien
sûr maintenant il ya une scène très
touchante c'est parce que ses parents
mais pas beaucoup d'argent et son père
le soir ils enlevaient les affaires de
la balise et il faisait un petit lit
dans la valise pour séverine c'est joli
c'est mignon comme tout l'or semble
avaliser l enfant s 80 m
voilà donc il retourne la réunion est là
dès l'âge de 4 ans vous vous rendez
compte que vous avez envie de faire du
spectacle tu très attiré par ce métier
moi je suis à treize mille kilomètres
une petite réunionnaise qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec ce métier je
regarde la télévision et ça me fascine
et je sais au fond de moi que je suis
que je suis fait pour ça mais pour moi
ça me paraît être tellement accessible
qu'à aucun moment ça me met fleurs
l'esprit que c'est vraiment moi fait des
petites chorégraphies
oui je commence sur gotainer
cette chanson voilà ça a été la première
c'est celle qui m'a donné envie de faire
des chorégraphies ensuite donc j'étais
les mini miss réunion à l'âge de 7 ans
et puis vous devenez un petit peu la
mascotte de lille non vous faites des
publicités pour la promotion de la
réunion va grâce à l'élection de mini
miss réunion
moi du coup tout a été lancée un peu
malgré moi donc j'ai appris j'ai appris
sur le tas et c'est vrai que mes parents
étaient pas du tout dans le métier donc
j'ai vraiment apprécié le terrain c'est
votre père qui s'occupe de tout il ya
des rumeurs qui commence à courir sur
lui ont dit qu il vous prend un peu
votre argent tout serait s'est vraiment
fait en tout cas mon père ne m'a jamais
réclamé un centime et il n'a jamais
voulu que j'aide mes parents dans des
situations plus ou moins critique donc
nantes où tout était vraiment en
harmonie en osmose tous ensemble jamais
eu ce genre de problème
alors vous raconter une scène très
difficile un traumatisme consécutif à la
révélation de la non-existence du père
noël
aïe ben oui ça paraît futile et c'est
important de le détruire les vies
entières et à des gens qui tombent dans
la dope à cause de ça mais c'est
possible quand on me dit que les oeufs
de pâques c'était une connerie ben
j'étais très énervé qui vous qui vous
est cher vous mais le passage du père
noël n'a pas peur qui est trop de gamins
qui laissent des plumes en lisant des
passages à un pearl a pas de livre parce
que je finis par an si jésus mais
j'étais bouleversé je me suis empressé
de l'oublier tout de suite je voulais
pas traîné il existe toujours mais là tu
vois alors oui bien là en fait vos
débuts d'animatrice à l'âge de 10 ans et
puis là c'est la rencontre avec un
dénommé luc russell alors lui c'est
vraiment la caricature du producteur
vous faites un petit groupe qui
s'appelle baby show vous êtes invités à
paris par patrick sabatier et lui alors
il prend ce que trop bien les mecs qui
font ça la production donne de l'argent
pour vous habitiez au concorde lafayette
et lui 20 ans dans un hôtel à châtillon
malakoff un regard des différents égards
la différence mais je la prends bien
plus tard je l'apprends par hasard je
reviens à paris je m'installe et un jour
l'assistante patrick savatier me laisse
en fait j'étais sur le passage clouté il
laisse le passage et je le reconnais
aillent tous étaient bien le concorde
lafayette
j'ai fait de quoi tu parles ah non non
pas du tout on était à châtillon
malakoff donc sans arrêt mais en même
temps aujourd'hui ce sont des souvenirs
qui restent il dit y avait sa prend aux
tripes quand même toutes ces histoires
c'est intéressant
non mais je trouve ça un peu violent
pour les gens qui vont toi c'est quand
même fort ce que tu racontes c'est pas
rien c'est pas des conneries c'est pas
anodin c'est pas anodin c'est d'espagne
ont marqué plusieurs générations de
préparer les gens prendre des
précautions oratoires avant de dire de
ce livre et les passages qui peuvent
heurter la sensibilité mais certains qui
sont très émouvant quand tu as fait la
queue à auch en 20 minutes
alors pourquoi me claire signe avec ce
producteur luc russell alors que c'est
de toute évidence à votre père en bleu
propose tout c'est bien que peu de temps
avant un producteur nous propose de
devenir de faire un single et en
l'occurrence il nous propose pas de nous
héberger de quelque part nous accueillir
et ce but nous propose tout ça
évidemment mon père et aujourd'hui je
comprends très bien puisque je suis une
maman aujourd'hui donc je comprends
vraiment ce qu'il a voulu faire essayer
de partir vers la sécurité et protéger
sa petite famille malheureusement ça n'a
pas été de bon sens et quand vous
arrivez à paris une buse à temps soit
disant il est pas là on est obligé
d'aller habiter dans un grenier
ouais c'est du bon sens les passages des
greniers ah non tu veux tout se faire
chier les gars ils auront le passé
occupé la salle de bain pour le coup
tout petit et là ils étaient obligés
quand même de le menacer
pour qu'il vous près de 117 mètres
carrés à boulogne le luxe a surtout que
la rentrée scolaire va démarrer qu'on
est toujours pas inscrit à l'école etc
c'est un peu dangereux
j'imagine la galère là maintenant on
rigole non mais j'imagine large mais
franchement je mets à votre place avec
vos parents avec les la grand mère elle
suivait toujours là bon heureusement je
dirais elle restait bien des choses à
tous les cas fait beaucoup de mal à vous
en débarrasser de ce producteur c'est
moi le mec qui imagine ici mais sur
cette famille c'est terrible a rien à
prendre soin mais heureusement je suis
là je pense qu'on n'aurait pas franchi
ouais je vais car beaucoup de mal à vous
en débarrasser votre père est obligé de
le menacer de le balancer au mari de sa
maîtresse délaissée mais ça a très bien
marché
il lui a dit si tu si tu continues et
ouais ouais j'ai dû constater je vais
dire on arrive à venir de sa famille
enjeux communs donc forcément ce moment
là on va vite vers l'extrême et on
trouve toutes les solutions plan et ça a
très bien marché puisqu'il a pris peur
et il a déchiré qu'on fera dans tous les
cas ça vous a pas empêché de faire
carrière mais c'est vrai que c'était une
époque permet très facilement et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que bon c'est vrai qu'on connaît en tant
qu'animatrice sur m6 mais on sait pas
par où je suis passé
et quelque part j'ai envie d'expliquer
que c'est pas si facile que ça
aujourd'hui l'impression que c'est très
facile de réussir mais c'est beaucoup de
travail et c'est du talent beaucoup de
rigueur et des belles anecdotes débats
et anecdotes mais qui forge un caractère
caractère bien trempé est ce que malgré
le fait qu'elle accepte même de
continuer à vivre alors que le père noël
n'existe pas de moi je dis chapeau bas
quel courage
l'inexistence du du père noël vous a pas
empêché de rencontrer le dalaï lama
heureusement quand même le grand moment
de votre vie séverine non c'était ben
c'était un canular car il n'existe qu'en
séverine voit le dalaï lama elle dit de
grosses larmes jaillissent et ruisselle
le long de mijoux est candidat il est là
ma voix c'est vrai il fait suivante
[ __ ] très beau sourire ce qui s'est
passé entre eux tous ces manques tu
arrives pas accompli par la presse
people moi qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
italie s'est passé non on disait à
séverine alain démarre à manger beaucoup
d'histoires dans les journaux dont voici
tous à des liaisons qui n'existaient pas
enfin des trucs
ouais c'est vrai et un jour elle dit je
vais en parler au dalaï lama mais quatre
comment vont-elles portable du jeu
résume ça s'est pas passé comme ça il se
trouvait c'est une période noire dans ma
vie
j'ai décidé de tout balancer de partir
pendant 1 mois et je suis parti je suis
très heureuse est parti quand vous voyez
vous donner une âme un bolide de grosses
larmes jaillissaient ruisselle le long
de mes jouets selon le dalaï lama
s'écrie c'est drôle je fais cet effet là
à toutes les femmes à la wii super drôle
on est super sympa papier venir il
éclate de rire tous les deux avec le
dalaï lama est heureuse dans les
inoubliables bien sûr jamais pour à
mésanger fabuleux et je le souhaite à
tout le monde
est-ce que c'est toujours les petits
mouchoirs en papier que le dalaï lama
vous a donné vous vous le gardez la
maison bien protégés tu es là un kleenex
dans sa table de nuit
un kleenex et m'a donné sa santé et toi
tu vois trois formes et sans objet
pratique le tir je sais davantage de
désacraliser un objet magnifique
non
[Applaudissements]
tous
m
dieu me pardonne on va vers une
interview dieu me pardonne
[Musique]
on va donner vie ensemble séverine
ferrer ce que vous avez à vous faire
pardonner
quel est le mensonge que dieu doit vous
pardonner d'avoir un petit peu menti en
amour de temps en temps ah bon tables et
si vous avez dit à des garçons vous les
émirs c'est pas vrai ça m'est arrivé
souvent des fois non je suis très
sincère mais il faut qu'on se rend
compte que c'est pas la bonne personne
mais un peu tard et on l'a déjà dit et
l'histoire d'amour que vous aimeriez que
dieu vous pardonne pas celle qui s'est
pas super bien terminé mais bon si
l'accueil au bail en a eu il sort d'un
manque été marquante et est le chanteur
un chanteur y en a eu plusieurs quatre
ans avec marcel amont
c'est là qu'elle s'est vraiment sérieux
c'est une histoire avec un garçon qui où
je suis resté assez longtemps 3 après
donc trois ans ce n'est pas rien dieu me
pardonne
[Musique]
à le gros mot que vous aimeriez que dieu
vous pardonne
j'ai tendance à dire pittet tout ça va
non je vais je suis assez sagement et la
drogue que vous aimeriez que dieu vous
pardonne jamais jamais jamais jamais
essayé oui c'est ça ma drogue c'est
l'amour ouais comme patrick sébastien
non c'est vrai nom est tu as peur d'être
un peu trop caricatural quand même des
rangs non parce que je suis comme ça je
vais pas me mentir je vais pas jouer à
la fille qu'il l'a fait alors qu'elle
l'a pas fait je suis honnête je suis
jamais rien points
non non je suis en phase avec moi-même
tout va bien et le vol que vous aimeriez
que dieu vous pardonne jamais fait un
tout petit à l'âge de 4 ans mais
attendez vous n'êtes pas ok podium là
pour dire la vérité je peux pas vous
mentir c'est vrai je n'ai jamais volé
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que dieu
vous pardonne alors d'avoir perdu autant
de temps avec des histoires qui n'ont
mais qui au merle à plusieurs
[Musique]
un moment j'ai cru de cette chanson
c'est un hommage à moi non non j'ai cru
que c'était un hommage à l'émission
présente peut-être peut-être qu'ils
s'aiment pourquoi ça peut marcher avec
lui ça ne regarde que nous vous
regrettez un peu de l'expérience
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais si nicolas rey
nicolas rey bonsoir séverine ferrer
mariée mère de famille très bien nicolas
rey célibataire prêt à tout ça va
nicolas très bien ah qu'il est beau non
oui il est vachement bien nicolas mais
magnifique
vous n'avez pas l'air convaincu secrète
pas au premier abord comme ça faut 20
minutes et un très bon et un très bon
regard mais en même temps vous êtes
mariés vous avez des enfants et c'est
surtout à croire au père noël
[Applaudissements]
me collard et donc après 13 minutes
mémoire courte et un début prometteur
vous publié au diable vauvert courir à
30 ans vous êtes un petit peu le
prototype de ce qu'on peut appeler le
nouvel avenant d'une certaine façon
pourquoi je sais pas vous avez cette
fragilité du nouvel homme le nouvel
homme pleure au cinéma non par exemple à
moi ça m'est arrivé de pleurer cinéma
injecterait pour un lundi matin au pathé
wepler pour sur la route de madison
parce que c'était lundi matin non non
c'était parce que j'avais pas encore vu
le film devait baffie que j'ai toujours
pas vu d'ailleurs mais je vais le voir
bien se marrer tout le monde te parle de
temps que j'ai envie de le voir
maintenant ses débuts au cinéma
c'est quand il était dans les salles ça
les dérangeait pas devenir un film culte
par exemple j'ai plus rien rien bambi tu
as quand même c'est quand le chasseur et
tu la maman tâche allait sous sa
nouvelle offre voilà madame c'est un mec
qui dit je t'aime uniquement par texto
c'est vrai nicolas bal et ouais enfin
par texto ouais c'est vrai que les
textos ça a changé pas mal de choses
sinon même mois passé des choses nous
envoyer des textos soulor s'est passé
les sentiments par les textos mais
plutôt à votre mari à vos amants comment
ça se passe c'est un nouvel homme le
nouvel ami les prêts à tout donner pour
un baiser mais rien pour une vie en
couple par exemple c'est vrai dans
l'instant oui c'est vrai est ce que le
nouvel homme pratique le cunnilingus
avant qu'on lui propose une fellation
la plus vive à voir ouais ça y va graver
l'intérêt même sens fellation un tu vas
heureusement c'est quand même un endroit
quand on fait l'amour avec quelqu'un
quand on baise avec quelqu'un c'est
quand même l'un des derniers endroits où
il n'y a pas de compétition on a un peu
la paix dont quand on a le droit
d'embrasser une fille entre les cuisses
sans forcément attendre comme dans le
libre échange une fellation en retour
quoi je pense donc c'est ça un nouvel
homme toi séverine si si vous n'avez pas
fait que vous voulez un fait ça donne
envie force est évidemment finalement
les jets ont bien reçu le message que je
pense que ça il va et veut même séverine
vous aimez donc
je sais bien que je gage m'en donnez
donc courir à 30 ans raconte la vie de
cinq homme de 30 ans confronté chacun au
choix de la séparation ou de
l'engagement dans le couple
bref être ou ne pas être ce que vous
appelez victime volontaire du couple ça
veut dire quoi ça victime volontaire du
couple c'est parce que quand même
aujourd'hui tout le monde a peur donc on
a peur quand on est célibataire et puis
on a peur aussi en temps des
célibataires on a peur de ne pas trouver
quelqu'un ne pas s'engager ne pas être
en couple et quand on est en couple on a
peur de ne jamais être à nouveau
célibataire donc et on a peur de tout on
a peur d'avoir un enfant on a peur de
jamais en avoir
on a constamment peur donc une victime
volontaire de la vie en couple c'est
quelqu'un qui à reculons décide à un
moment donné de se mettre en couple
à défaut d'avoir réalisé un peu le
l'idéal amoureux qui l'avait quand il
avait 14 ans et puis regardez vite
verrai ton à la boum 2 cambre d'aze
ambri toi oui j'ai compris et je suis
assez d'accord avec lui on peut choisir
est sauf la fin il a merdé
j'ai décroché mais c'est vrai que tout
le monde a peur les gens ont peur de
s'engager ils ont peur de take quelqu'un
l'a peut-être quelqu'un tu as peur
d'avoir de ne pas avoir de pas pouvoir
avoir des enfants tu as peur dans la
voix cca victime volontaire du couple
ben oui c'est ça au montage tu t'en fous
oui je crois il intéresse a commencé
parce que j'ai pas compris alors courir
à 30 on raconte la vie de cinq homme de
30 ans confronté chacun au choix de la
la séparation ou l'engagement dans le
couple bref être ou ne pas être ce que
vous appelez une victime volontaire du
couple c'est quoi une victime volontaire
du couple ces calculs
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
particulier
c'est quoi je vais essayer je crois que
c'est clair dire quelque chose à voir
des galères
c'est à dire en fait je vais essayer
d'expliquer les choses un peu ça plus
simplement en fait par exemple prenons
l'exemple de séverine séverine avec
frédéric samson il avait pris les
risques avant d'inscrire c'est compliqué
d'expliquer la lenteur du tibia et
séverine par exemple et comme nous tous
un une victime volontaire de la vie en
couple c'est à dire qu avant d'inscrire
dans le temps une histoire dans sa vie
amoureuse séverine a eu d'autres
histoires avant non je pense avec des
pétards des gentils et en fait avant de
t'engager avec frédéric tu vois là est
inconnu avant d'engager de t'engager
avec frédéric tu as eu un peu peur quoi
en fait
elle a fallu que je passe par là pour me
rendre compte enfin de me rendre compte
que c'était vraiment le bon donc non je
suis le couple c'est magique
ben on lui dit que tu es une victime de
lenteurs du couple non mais c'est vrai
qu'à un moment on a toujours peur s'est
jamais le moment n'est jamais prêt pour
un enfant on n'est pas sûr tu sais mais
je t'aime moi non plus et un moment si
on n'ose pas les choses on y viendra
jamais donc je suis très heureuse et
puis je suis en couple senior une
victime volontaire du lookbook aux
lettres saleh la patate nico longtemps
de l'avion en couple c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui
qui a peur et qui va malgré tout et en
même temps donc il se considère comme
une victime volontaire donc cette
personne a peur d'ouvrir les verts
perdent
bon alors c'est simple une victime
volontaire de la vie en couple s'est
passé pas compliquer une victime
volontaires de la ville
est ce que ton éditeur il est là ou pas
parce qu'elle doit être lisse en grande
forme
une victime volontaire de la vie en
couple
gt c'est quelqu'un qui accepte de nos
jours et ce n'est pas évident l'amour
sans les détritus ce voilà ça c'est
cette voie là bas ce sera coupée au
montage qui arrivait enfin là c'est
simple avant en gros nos grands parents
pour donner des exemples un peu concrets
pour éviter que certaines personnes ne
comprennent pas avant nos grands parents
quand ils avaient du pain par exemple le
lendemain le pain dur il en fait il le
transformait en levure il le donnée aux
poules ils ont fait du pain perdu
lendemain matin et de nos jours on zappe
tout c'est pas évident d'inscrire une
histoire non pas dans la durée parce que
si on n'a pas droit de citer de marque
mais dans le couple et à partir de là
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
à partir de là on est tous là en fait à
zapper en permanence la tête assure
séverine et pas assez grande on zappe de
séverine non il faut garder séverine
avec sa taille de lolita c'est essentiel
il faut inscrire une histoire dans le
temps c'est à dire que si vous vous de
regret si vous voulez en parler il faut
aimer c'est vrai et que vous pris avec
ses défauts bien avec ses fantômes j'ai
compris avec ses névroses oui alors
c'est ça une victime volontaire de la
vie en couple c'est elle qui est le
contenu de ses défauts mais voilà
pourquoi tu veux pas du tout
si tu veux vraiment savoir
il a 30 ans raconte la venue de cinq
heures de 30 en mai et qui en anglais
sur le plan moi j'aurais mis deux heures
à courir non ah ouais tu mettrais 2h toi
alors on va prendre quelques hommes
parmi parmi les cinq que vous décrivez
nicolas rey ya franck alors vous avez
une phrase qui est très jolie d'ailleurs
en parlant de francs vous dites les vies
sont ainsi faites elles tiennent le coup
des décennies entières puis bascule sur
un baiser et c'est vrai il est heureux
il est en coupe justement des puits
rencontre une femme il sait que ça va
être
voilà c'est ça va être une catastrophe
jeudi va quand même assez comme ça on a
la sensation parfois d'accéder à une
certaine sérénité une certaine
tranquillité d'avoir enfin trouvé un
équilibre
et puis d'avoir enfin quelques
certitudes
et puis c'est pas du tout prévu tu te
réveille un matin et puis tu crois que
quelqu'un est sur un baiser toute ta vie
va basculer tu dois faire encore et
parfois comme ça le temps se rétrécit
sur quelques sur quelques secondes quoi
il va pas faire tel corps de l'un mais
c'est vachement bien un centre pourtant
doller et et donc des enquêtes craque
pour cette gonzesse
mais ça c'est en fait il ya un film de
hal hartley cap a très bien marché mais
qui était très bien qui s'appelle qui
n'a pas très bien marché
c'est bizarre non les gens n'osent pas
ils n'osent pas parler de film qui
marche verte commencé il ya un film qui
a eu un grand succès d'estimé de celle
qui va devenir culte bien débuté oui en
dvd qu'un film de hal hartley mais il ya
d'autres films qui vont avoir ce même
destin et s'appelle le titre c'est reste
me et est en fait l'histoire de francs
que ça vient de là c'est qu'à un moment
dans le trust me le héros du film tombe
amoureux comme ça alors qu'il est marié
que sa vie un peu rangé comme ça dans
dans une armoire comme dans un com le
bonheur parfois rangés dans une armoire
et puis comme août un anglais la vie
rangée dans une valise et en fait et en
fait donc il ya ce truc là et le type
dit à la jeune fille
dans ce monde il ya deux choses les
ennuis et le désir 1
le problème c'est que à partir du moment
où tu commences à désirer quelqu'un sait
les ennuis qui commence voilà donc voilà
c'est ce qui arrive à franck en fait
tant qu'il n'avait pas désiré quelqu'un
et c'est à ce moment là où les
emmerdements commence alors lui il
craque complètement sur elle elle l
aimait les plus jeunes que lui
hélas cette phrase qui correspond à
transmis il faut avoir un peu confiance
ouais c'est joli il ya elle qui a eu
tant de moins qui lui dit peut avoir un
peu confiance
il ya vincent si vincent pas on va sans
livre c'est que célibataire il redevient
sénateurs
mais bien son bouquin j'en suis sûr et
on le dit en rigolant je pense que les
gens sont morts de rire chez eux
non le bouquin à traîner il redevient
célibataire mais la vie lui fait
ex-pilier le choix de sa liberté
en fait ils rentrent ils rencontrent
enfin moi elle s'appelait je me souviens
plus du nom
qui dit la belgique tu sais les nerfs
n'est pas bénédicte ok merci ça fait dix
ans qu'on se bat c'est du team de
l'avion tu es tu vois que par le à
l'église saint vincent en fait
vincent durand devient maçon dumas pas
célibataire c'est lequel va redevenir
célibataire alors vincent retour on va
l'appeler cécile parce que sicile après
tout ça donc
cécile déjà c'est qu'on arrive à passer
nicolas vincent retrouve cécile oui
voilà qui dans la chambre et le colonel
moutarde
alors c'est simple pourquoi parce que
vincent retrouve en fait
cécile cécile et son premier amour son
premier amour en classe de cm1 quand il
faisait du théâtre comme souvent quand
on est enfin on fait du théâtre bien sûr
mais bien sûr y voilà et en fait c'est
son premier amour à jamais disparu donc
c'est toute la thématique de courir à 30
ans voyez-vous ce que je veux dire
et pourtant ça c'est à dire que avant on
passe son temps à courir quand on est
enfant par exemple quand quel âge at on
enfin je ne sais pas trois ans et demi
bas voilà à 3h30
il marche j'en ai très bien lui il
accepte le mariage avec vous avez ce mot
terrible
la détestation de l'autre vous pensez
que dans tout couple dans tout mariage
il ya forcément une détestation de
l'autre parent j'espère pas de façon
comme ça continue elle met de temps à
autre dans un grand moment de m moi et
temps à autre dans un lit tu te couches
avec ta femme tes à quelques millimètres
d'elle et pourtant il ya un océan qui te
sépare d'elle et tu la vois là mais
c'est la règle du jeu il faut l'accepter
il faut accepter de détester l'autre si
c'est un bon début c'est comme la
dépression nerveuse il faut accepter
d'aller mal c'est pas une si mauvaise
chose il faut accepter de faire un bide
au cinéma c'est un bon début
[Applaudissements]
oui on va pas s'en sortir ne vais pas
terrible des phrases sur la fidélité est
une vertu qui s'exerce par défaut
français dans ta gueule
quel sens dit sa hâte en laisse lui un
peu de temps dans trois mois dans trois
semaines un autre personnage louis que
les baby sitter d'une gamine de 11 ans
qui lui saute dessus pour l'embrasser
en fait c'est l'histoire d'un pédophile
qui ne l'est pas puisque comme j'écris
d'encourir à 30 ans il y à quelques
mètres de la rubrique des faits divers
mais ne monte pas dans la chambre de
clara et c'est ce qui m'intéressait
c'est la différence entre les nous est
ce qu'on appelle un meurtrier un nas a
fait un pédophile un monstre qu'est ce
qui nous distingue à un moment donné
nous de ces gens-là qu'on donne enfin en
toiture en pâture je cherchais le mot
exact
ouais c'est ça en pâture donc voilà
c'est parfois c'est une feuille de
papier à cigarette donc c'est ça qui
m'intéressait c'était de raconter ça
quoi voilà alors les piles tu suis là
j'ai repris je vais te faire la cité et
ses gars voilà paul et les autres
comment les pilotes l'auteur à 70 ans il
ya cette phrase terrible
écrire est un métier aussi dégoûtant
qu'un autre un métier où plus personne
n'a le choix il faut aller aux
signatures il faut faire semblant
d'écouter les gens qui parlent de tes
livres
il faut être capable de faire commerce
de sa vie privée pour dix mille
exemplaires de plus l'époque modiano est
terminée c'est fini écrivait alors non
parce que le fils répond non c'est toi
qui t'es corrompus c'est toi qui qui a
choisi le père dit non je n'avais pas le
choix à ce moment là il fallait il
fallait faire commerce de sa vie privée
pour vendre dix mille exemplaires de
plus et est en fait le fisc lui dit on a
toujours le choix y compris de ne pas
faire commerce de ce à quoi
voilà donc non je pense que c'est pas
fini loin de là et heureusement
d'ailleurs
la preuve le clézio se vend très bien en
ce moment donc non c'est plutôt une
bonne chose mais je en même temps
évidemment dernier chapitre c'est
c'était une façon à moi de pouvoir
raconter ce que j'avais vécu depuis mes
premiers livres
c'est à dire que j'ai aussi joué sur le
fait de faire commerce un peu de ce que
j' étais quoi hein et de ma vie privée
et souvent on a attaqué ou poser des
questions là-dessus
et puis j'avais envie d'en d'en parler
parce que c'est du bien d'en parler mais
non mais c'est en fait la promo c'est un
truc marrant là on rigole et tout mais
dans trois mois quand ça sera fini ça te
rend très triste tu te dis mais jusqu'où
je suis allé pour vendre mon livre je
vais vraiment il fallait faire ça ou pas
ça va voilà ça va plutôt bien en
découlent on a rigolé non c'était cool
vrai mais non mais c'est un vrai truc
bien sûr c'est normalement la cdca cher
que tu vends mon garçon c'est clair mais
normalement un écrivain c'est déjà assez
chiant cloud afin de passer deux ans à
faire du mieux possible pour faire un
livre
et en plus après il faut il faut
vraiment mouillé sa chemise mais c'est
vraiment
[Musique]
porto s'est évité au diable aux leurs
messieurs
[Musique]
et maintenant
et les propos des bâtons
si jean michel cousteau
[Musique]
jean michel cousteau bonsoir bonsoir
séverine ferrer nicolas rey laurent
baffie jean michel cousteau qui est donc
le fils aîné du commandant cousteau
voilà alors séverine pendant l'émission
c'est à dire mal à suivre
si tout va bien tu es comme ça et si ça
va mal tu fais comme ça voilà ce qui
s'était passé tout comme ça et si l'on
se fait tout comme ça il a l'habitude si
tu manques des rediffs est comme ça
alors jean michel proust vous publier
mon père le commandant à l'archipel avec
cette extraordinaire photo de couverture
au moment où à l'âge de 7 ans votre père
comme vous dites vous jette à la baille
et c'est vrai que c'est une photo que
j'adore parce qu'il ya dans le regard
quelque chose d'à la fois confiant et
anxieux c'est magnifique s'est souvenu
souviens très bien de toutes ces années
avec mon frère qui était plus jeune qui
lui avait été poussé par dessus bord il
avait 4 ans et demi et puis on nous
emmener pendant les week-ends pendant
les vacances sont allés se baigner nager
plonger alors que nos petits camarades
d'école où il allait à la montagne pas
du ski on pensait que c'était tout à
fait normal
donc si vous voulez j'ai eu le privilège
d'être un des premiers grâce à mettre à
l'eau alors ensuite pendant 40 ans
effectivement vous avez sillonné les
mers à bord de la calypso pour réaliser
votre rêve construire des maisons sous
la mer ou donné architectes vous avez
fait des maisons sous la mer n'ont
jamais non j'attends toujours mon
premier client
lepage à breslau et puis vous avez
réalisé produit de nombreux films
évidemment consacré à l'océanographie à
l'environnement alors votre livre
commence par l'enterrement du commandant
cousteau a beaucoup de livres qui
commence pour les enterrements
le livre de nicole calfan enterrement
côte film aussi un advergame enterrement
la comtesse aux pieds nus oui
effectivement enterrement mais elle
apprend raconte la vie voilà c'est début
d'une fin voilà c'est un bon truc c'est
le 30 juin 1997 notre dame de paris
des funérailles quasi nationale
en présence du président la république
pour le fameux commandant cousteau
l'homme au bonnet rouge
et là on voit la veuve du commandant
francine avec ses deux enfants francine
qui la deuxième épouse donc du
commandant cousteau
vous citez jamais son prénom dans le
livre pourquoi parce que je pense que
c'est un personnage qui n'appartient pas
vraiment à l' aventure cousteau ah
d'accord
donc c'est pour ça vous ne citez pas son
prénom tout laventure cousteau s'est
arrêté en fait si vous voulez le jour où
ma mère est morte ma mère je dédie ce
bouquin à ma mère ce qui veut dire que
sans ma mère le commandant cousteau
n'ont jamais été cette vérité et le jour
de sa mort prématurée
mon père s'est liquéfiée littéralement
et à ce moment là vous repensé au
deuxième mariage du commandant quand il
a épousé 7,7 francine et en fait il
n'avait pas le droit de se marier deux
fois l'église parce que ça c'est
parfaitement interdit alors voulu poser
la question est en fait il vous répond
que grâce au révérend père carré il a
obtenu le droit de se marier deux fois
et vous découvrez que quand on est
académicien finalement ça ça aide
moi j'ai trouvé ça choquant ça le
regarde s il était en paix avec lui-même
1 ceci étant personnellement je trouve
ça très choquant mais c'est assez dur
quand vous le décrivez à genoux la
langue pendante pour recevoir l'hostie
c'est assez violent quand même ces
violences ce sens que s'ils voulaient
j'étais absolument choquée de voir mon
père qui ne pratiquaient pas d'un seul
coup se liquéfier littéralement parquet
pour le commandant cousteau et dans ça
fait deux fois que vous disent assez
fier c'est bien alors son premier
mariage le commandant cousteau c'est
avec votre votre mère donc on a beaucoup
dit que c'était un bon mariage qui à
l'époque était quand même une façon de
dire que c'est un maillage d'argent non
non ce n'est pas un mariage d'argent
c'était un mariage d'amour qui en
l'occurrence a permis à ma mère qui
rêvait d'être dans la marine
or à l'époque les femmes n'avaient pas
droit d dans la marine et de ce fait
elle a fait ce qu'il y avait de mieux à
faire c'était d'en épouser un un marin
oui on dirait qu'à lui ça lui a permis
de pénétrer dans le milieu des affaires
comme un salut a permis sur dix dans ça
lui a permis d'ouvrir des portes
ouais alors quand votre belle mère
francine cousteau était sur ce plateau
on lui a parlé évidemment des
accusations d'antisémitisme dont votre
père a été victime
et cette fameuse lettre de 1941 le
commandant couche-tôt vient d'arriver à
marseille
il a une famille une femme et enfants il
n'arrive pas à se loger est il écrit une
lettre en disant il n'y aura
l'appartement convenable que quand on
aura fichu à la porte tous les ignobles
loutres qui nous encombre alors moi j'ai
découvert ça comme vous il ya deux ans
ou trois ans j'avais jamais entendu mon
père avoir des commentaires de ce genre
là je trouve ça extrêmement regrettable
bien sûr c'était une lettre privée qui
était destiné aux commandants tayeb qui
a qui a été
trouvez distribués mais il faut se
mettre dans le contexte de l'époque nous
étions quatre dans une chambre à
marseille au sixième étage et on pouvait
pas avoir de logement alors que les
réfugiés qui venaient d'un peu partout
eux on leur donnait des appartements de
plusieurs pièces dont il ya eu un sou
les a ras-le-bol il ya eu un geste
malheureux de sa part est regrettable
est que je condamne voilà alors après le
passage de votre belle mère dans cette
émission on a reçu un mail le fils d'un
ancien collaborateur de votre père qui
l'accusé d'avoir déposé à son nom cette
idée de détendeur qui a fait sa fortune
bien entendu qu'il avait piqué un
certain emile gagnant alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que ce détendeur c'est
quelque chose d'énorme c'était la fin du
dew de gros scaphandre donc c'était une
avancée extraordinaire le le beau père
de mon père qui était un officier de
marine qui travaillait pour l'air
liquide après sa retraite avait mis en
contact mon père avec un ingénieur de
l'air liquide
ouais et c'est emile gagnant pour
améliorer un système qui existait déjà
qui avait été inventé par le commandant
le prieur et avant le commandant prieur
qui avait été inventé par les roucayrol
denayrouze à espalion dans l'aveyron a
donné ce détendeur votre père il l'a
piqué où il leur a donné la balle piquée
du tout il a ils ont adapté tous les
deux
ainsi vous regardez le brevet ça
s'appelle cousteau gagne en pro b
cousteau gagnant donc l'idée sombre où
les autres et à lannion à gagnant car
votre père l'idée a été partagé entre
les deux vous pouvez parler à la fille
de monsieur gagnant qui toujours en vie
à une femme extraordinaire d'ailleurs
avec qui j'ai plongé a pas très
longtemps et il n'y a jamais eu
d'amertume à ce niveau là en tous les
cas pour pouvoir faire les
et c'est son détendeur votre père donc
le commandant cousteau a fait appel à
son frère qui à l'époque était quand
même un personnage haut placé de la
france collaborationniste c'est pierre
antoine courteault rédacteur en chef de
je suis partout journal fasciste et
d'ailleurs pierre antoine a été condamné
à mort à la libération il a été gracié
donc n'était pas antisémite mais enfin
c'est quand même servi de son frère qui
était un ponte de la collaboration pour
faire avancer son idée de détendeur je
ne sais pas exactement comment ça s'est
passé j'étais beaucoup trop jeune
là encore et je n'étais même pas à paris
j'étais à megève donc je je ne suis pas
un témoin direct et je n'en connais pas
vous avez l'air perplexe je suis
perplexe parce que je voulais parce que
c'est la vérité parce que votre père
quand il eu besoin de faire ces essais
dans la marne il a il a demandé la tenue
il a demandé à son frère ce que telle
logique vous ne lirez d'une certaine
façon
enfin sauf que ça n'avait absolument
rien à voir avec la position que pouvait
avoir son frère qui était mon âge que je
n'ai pratiquement pas connu que ce soit
elle était en prison soit il était
malade il est mort du cancer très jeune
après avoir être libéré et si vous avez
besoin d'un renseignement vous avez
besoin d'une permission
vous allez voir les gens qui peuvent
vous la donner ça absolument rien à voir
avec la position politique ou antisémite
éventuelle de son frère un peu à un
éventuel arrêt pendant mais quand on
dirige je suis partout pendant la guerre
de 40 c'est pas éventuel l'antisémitisme
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
je peux pas vous répondre là dessus
parce que je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
vraiment passé alors autre reproche
couramment adressé à cousteau et que
vous abordez dans le livre c'est le fait
d'avoir maltraité des animaux et des
le monde du silence on parle de quelques
cachalot sacrifié en fait pour une
reconstitution il ya eu il ya deux
choses à dire il ya eu un accident un
accident où effectivement la calypso est
passé sur un bébé cachalot hélas aussi
sonné ce qui a été absolument dramatique
et il ya eu des reconstitutions qui ont
eu lieu plus tard avec d'autres animaux
n'oubliez pas nous étions des pionniers
on faisait les erreurs que font tous les
pionniers qu'on peut nous reprocher
aujourd'hui mais ça nous a appris ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire ouais et vient
aussi les lions de mer la pépite au et
cristobal la pépite au et cristobal
pareil et ils sont morts qua non à sa
fille ana qui a été empoisonné par une
enquête impôts buffles et cristobal
oui ils avaient un poids zones est et
l'autre qui a été mis sur une île et
fait relâcher au pérou alors qu'il vient
de madagascar
tout ça c'est de l'histoire ancienne si
vous voulez et et du nord et vous
comprendrez excuses aux mines mais
j'espère qu'on va aller on va aller là
le premier mans c'est qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant ces cinquante ans
ouais si vous quand même pas oublier que
le commandant cousteau et son équipe ont
fait connaître la mer à la terre entière
et que peut être après l'abbé pierre et
le général de gaulle c'est le personnage
au plus connu sur les prés le personnage
français le plus connu sur la planète
donc il ya une raison une raison quand
même dans le positif
tu sais tout ça toi non mais sinon toi
séverine tu aime tout ce qui est
langoustines crevettes rtas et
bigorneaux les bulots les frères même
c'est que l'élan tu es déjà dans un âge
est une raie géante gens vous serez pas
venez pas de physique on a des élans
lustres les processions des langoustes
et la procession de langoustes comme les
crevettes est commuée
aucun ce sont les éboueurs de la mer
alors vous vous régaler avec des
électrodes des animaux qui les ramassent
les morts les blessés et mal formés qui
s'est longuement les crabes les
araignées sont les langues où ça va
aussi aller omar aussi oui et les
huîtres alors parlons pas des usa bon et
filtrauto qu'un salarié vous manger tout
en plus comment manger un poisson vous
enlevez louait le coeur le foie accès à
la une huître ou danger votre père était
pas tendre avec les animaux on vient de
le voir mais pas non plus avec les gens
il était très dur non à sa veste et dur
parce qu'ils étaient très déterminés ils
savaient vous voulez aller et dans la
mesure du possible rien ne l'arrêté
ouais ouais c'était aussi bien avec sa
famille qu avec des gens qui l'entourent
avec vous il a été terrible vous avez
ouvert un truc qui s'appelait le
cousteau fidji island resort six états
qui s'appelle maintenant le jean michel
cousteau
c'est un complexe touristique dans le
pacifique sud et si vous avez un procès
sans même vous appeler il m'a intenter
un procès m'a pas fait un procès à
intenter un procès qui a été arrêté et
j'ai mis mon nom mon prénom devant mon
nom toute ma vie moi j'avais fait du
cousteau et puis d'un seul coup dont
j'ai eu l'honneur de mettre nos prénoms
devant oeuvre ceci étant vous savez
malheureusement à l'époque où ça ça
s'est passé alors que mon père m'avait
dit tu sais les avocats il faut jamais
se mettre de l'impact parce que c'est
eux qui gagnent et les autres perdent
toujours
asseyons-nous autour d'une table avec
une bonne bouteille de pinard et on
règle nos problèmes
1 et bien malheureusement il ya eu des
gens au milieu qui ont interféré à une
époque oui oui commençait à vieillir et
ça s'est mal passé c'est devenu très
public mais je peux vous dire qu'il ya
aucune amertume d'un côté comme de
l'autre cas c'est parler après et j
michel c'était francine qui le je ne
peux pas vous répondre à cette question
parce que je n'ai pas je n'ai pas si
vous voulez de preuves tangibles
d'accord bien en tous les cas votre
livre est effectivement un hommage à
votre père mais sa statue sur un petit
peu ébréché tout ça non quand même non
je pense pas je pense c'est un
personnage absolument extraordinaire qui
nous a appris beaucoup de choses et je
lui en suis très reconnaissant il ya
quand même des années durant comme une
scène terrible à un moment votre frère
philippe un accident d'hydravion son
corps tombent dans le tages ont retrouve
son corps et au moment d'aller
reconnaître à la morgue
votre père n'y va pas et vous envoie
vous va nous on attend du commandant
cousteau qui lie à et qu'il soit
courageux enfin voila c'est captain
planet quoi et il n'y va pas le captain
planet avait une tendance à déléguer
tout ce qui était désagréable
ouais et en l'occurrence ça a été très
dur pour moi et j'aurais fait pour vous
c'est tejedor j'obéis aux commandants et
ensuite c'est quand même beau frère
votre mère parce que le héros principal
du bouquin c'est votre mère enfin cessé
à merci bah oui de me le rappeler bien
sûr un site si j'avais écrit un livre
sur ma mère et il ya d'autres gens qui
ont essayé
je ne serai pas là ce soir or comme j'ai
je présente mon père qui est connu tout
le monde ça me permet d'une façon
détournée mais de vraiment maintenant
voilà excusez moi mais à un moment votre
mère est malade à la fin elle est
victime d'un cancer généralisé elle
était à monaco il s'en occupe pas
beaucoup il débarque la veille de sa
mort elle a attendu qu'il fasse surface
si j'ose dire oui pour s'éteindre dans
ses bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors jean michel cousteau mon père le
commandant s'était dit et à l'archipel
et maintenant on va faire comme votre
père on va s'amuser avec les poissons
on va faire un quiz un quiz fiche non
vous allez vous opposez tous les deux
assauts locaux isli souhait alors
attention
qu'est ce qu'une astéries est le maître
mot
[Applaudissements]
alors attention que se passe-t-il
laurent concentre toi
concentrez-vous jean-michel que se
passe-t-il quand on casse une branche
des toiles de mer à leur poule bon vous
demandais si c'était un piège
je suis méfiant mais parmi les espèces
comptes et des points régis serge s'il
vous plaît pour le moment ça fait un
partout
attention jean michel laurent combien de
coeur à une pieuvre a hobo public à quel
animal à près de 9000 dans le requin non
non la lamproie non quel animal à plus
de 9000 dans c'est vrai quoi
je ne sais pas mais pourquoi tu sais pas
encore qui vit à la réunion un animal
marin un animal marin mais là on est
dans le fish quiz coelacanthe non non
harper donnez votre langue au chat par
contre ce que c'est le poisson chat
waouh c'est un poisson chat parce qu'il
y avait beaucoup d après son achat
d'accord attention quel est l'animal qui
a le plus grand cerveau au monde
c'est un ado oui kg 2 pour un animal de
15 mètres de long sur vous citer
quelques requins vous allez me dire
celui qui n'existe pas à oignies alors
maroni ça existe alors si le requin
taupe le requin taureau le requin zèbre
ou le requin chèvre lequel n'existent
pas eh ben non chef saison 2 pour
jean-michel allons-y à combien de temps
vit un esturgeon sentant non 90 ans non
80 à 60 ans non entend par là 110 en on
attend 150 non ce n'était pas aux
enchères c'est moi comptons personne a
répondu un esturgeon jusqu'à son temps
et d'argent
j'étais quand c'est vrai c'est vrai à me
donner un de mes points un demi point
pour jean michel et moi je persiste à
dire que ça vit plus longtemps que ça ça
peut vivre jusqu'à 100 ans un esturgeon
ah bon on est dans la volga tout ça il
ya des spécimens de trois mètres mal et
de ceux qui sont dans les boîtes non
malades très intéressant quelle est la
longueur moyenne d'une bits de baleines
en érection de massy cipriani 2 mètres
40 arabe audit de notre exactement 2
mètres 40
excusez moi mais maintenant mais on est
inquiet que j'ai tjrs et pas non gt gt
pas tout à fait la langue est un peu
court dans la baie dans la vie vous avez
dit dans la bible excusez moi jean
michel on parlait de quelle espèce parce
qu'il y en a des pâtis des plus grands
ce domaine attendait il faut il faut
quand même faut quand même pas charrier
parce que vous êtes vous avez des
petites baleines les grandes baleines
si vous prenez une baleine bloqués
l'animal le plus grand qui ait jamais
existé sur la planète yoga qu'elle
apprend m de long way et bien sa dette
encore plus grand que ce que vous devez
s'y rendre c'est de dire j'ai vu des
deux mètres j'ai vu plein que j'ai des
deux mètres et où j'ai visé deux mètres
parce que quand vous avez vous avez bien
que quand quand c'est quand vous avez un
jeune mâle qui est en train d'apprendre
à faire l'amour et que un vieux mâle est
là pour l'assister et une femelle au
milieu de tout ça et bien vous laisser
vous et c'est verges extraordinaire de
très belles qui sait jamais
absolument remarquable et qui ballot
j'avais un ingénieur du son absolument
extraordinaire effondré qu'ils étaient
fatigués après une journée épuisante on
était tous dans un zodiac en train de se
balancer elle dit dans une petite voix
des verges sur la gauche et a tout de
suite et caméras en branle
c'est un nom quel est le point commun
entre un mérou une dorade grise et un
poisson années me change de sexe ils
sont trop sexuel avec ces poissons il y
en a beaucoup d'autres espaces il y en a
qui deviennent un mal il ya de revient
de vienne femelles et c'est une histoire
de deux qui dominent quoi mais vous
pouvez pas savoir quel est le sexe d'un
de ces poissons hein
et quand vous êtes en présence par
exemple des mérous et on la filme mais
j'ai des photos qui vous met qu'il ya
une âme héros qui fait 120 kg à peu près
il agit qui vous met comme une loche qui
vous mettent leur sexe sur la tête ce
qui m'est arrivé et qui vous pousse
jusqu'au fond et qui vous écrasent on se
pose des questions
qu'est ce que la pieuvre argonauts et
détonnant pour se reproduire avec son
tentacules elle met le son
spermatozoïdes son sperme dans la ville
de la famille les tentacules de la
petite pièce rare et a chargé de sperme
et park à la recherche d'une femelle de
spermatophores et thomas temps forts
rien
quel est l'autre nom du carassins doré
auquel est l'autre nom du quart à saint
do ré c'est vraiment ce que c'est qu'un
carassins d'abord nicolas l'autre nom du
quart à sens de sardines
c'est pas loin c'est un poisson très
simple rascasse non tu très très simple
le gobie le bal au xénon alors c'est le
poisson rouge
jean-michel pourquoi jean michel
pourquoi la mer est bleue et bleu à
cause de la réfraction de la lumière
bravo laurent pourquoi la mer rouge et
rouge
elle est rouge à cause du du peloton qui
la color ou du sel elle est rouge
oui elle parce qu'elle contient des les
oxydes et des chaires des ténors des dés
et les routes soit s'il contient des des
non non non l'écran même des algues
microscopiques
alors certes ce qu'elle est le score 6-3
et demi je suis désolé jean michel vous
vous êtes fait torcher par le rendra
plus comme un art voix jean michel
cousteau mon père le commandant s'est
évité
si belle
[Musique]
non je te félicite a été exemplaire
vraiment ça m'a fait plaisir
il adore ce salon vous êtes libre hier
sur yes non mais elle cherche un exploit
mais bon franchement je crois on est en
ce moment en train de suivre des
baleines que nous avons marqué avec des
bouquets satellites et on a besoin
d'experts on a besoin de gens qui savent
de quoi il s'agit vous êtes prêts moi je
suis prêt je pars demain laurent ça
tombe bien je suis libre soit on change
pas de nom givet moisséens la vie peut
basculer
il n'y a pas que ma vie et j'ai aussi le
mal de mer s'est pour sa part à des
pilules non c'est plus un problème
extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si jean edouard lipa
ça
[Musique]
jean-edouard j'ai bien dit li pas parce
que ce soir ce n'est pas le lofteur que
nous recevons mais le comédien mesdames
messieurs et on l'applaudît
[Applaudissements]
qu'il y arrive bien
voir les musiciens survie
trois ans après l' aventure du premier
loft sur m6
jean-edouard vous avez décidé de prendre
votre carrière en main et de vous lancer
à fond dans le métier d'acteur
après des cours au studio pygmalion vous
avez décroché votre premier rôle et vous
serez à partir du 16 avril sur scène à
l'espace pierre cardin à la fiche de
jésus la can avec marie laforêt c'est
une pièce de francis carco adapté par
frédéric dard mari joue fernande et vous
bat le rôle-titre jésus lacaille le rôle
d'un prostitué homosexuel
voilà comme quoi le loft mène à tout mon
cher ami
voilà je regardais à dieu tu te souviens
de jean-edouard évidemment voilà j'ai
regardé le loft et j'ai regardé les
trucs qui étaient considérées comme les
pires à chaque fois j'ai regardé le loft
1 le loft 2 et nice people donc vraiment
les endroits où ils ne font rien et je
trouvais ça plus intéressant que les
endroits où on doit vraiment un exemple
devenir une star de la chanson se faire
ennuyé par un prof de sport genre
tiburce tu vois qu'il kiffe vraiment
qu'ils se quittent features c'est le
prof de sport de la star academy avoir
tout pourri la vie constamment et là
j'aimerais bien côté un peu totalement
décadent il foutait rien tu vas bon lui
au début c'est un peu amusé enfin tout
le monde le sait la première nuit quoi
mais on va inventer un détendeur
il a pratiqué mais en dessous des
centaines l'ennui tu vas tu gagnais le
délabrement mais tu as raison il y avait
dans le premier loft et dans le deuxième
une dimension warholienne mais oui comme
le mec qui dort pendant huit heures dans
le tunnel à maurice et penser qu'à
bouffer plus ou moins car c'était une
sorte de délabrement moral et physique
au fur et à mesure et c'était vraiment
intéressant à regarder les voulez bien
montrer aussi fin et c'est pour bientôt
dire aussi que c'est monté que c'est
clair qu'on passait le plus grand et du
coup j'ai eu pas mal de temps de lui qui
est fou amoureux de lui
ben alors et il est là d'ailleurs il
s'appelle louis les nerfs il est où
et je suis sûr il est là il est un bruit
il est la leur il s'est senti bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir oui mais voilà écoute
franchement pas faire voilà qu'est ce
que tu fais dans la ville oui je suis
très content d'être invitée ce soir
c'est vraiment un grand bonheur pour moi
c'est vrai que je suis également auteur
dans la même maison d'édition que
nicholas ray mais c'est pas du tout pour
ça que je suis venu ici au diable
vauvert voilà sar un pur roman avant
l'annoncé
voilà début mai c'est un pur
chef-d'oeuvre donc c'est vrai en plus
[Applaudissements]
inouïes qu'est ce qui se passe avec jean
edouard
alors en fait on l'a compris je suis pas
du tout là pour ma promo absolument pas
je suis là pour faire une vraie
déclaration d'amour à jean edouard
également à séverine ferrer
il aime beaucoup ses vraies stars aussi
les deux c'est un petit peu un pack moi
j'étais très amoureux de séverine ya des
gens il ya des gens qui sont bisexuels
l'huile est un peu ovni sexuée quoi ils
et les voilà il est au taquet tout le
temps j'étais très amoureuse tendre de
séverine quand elle avait 7 ans qu'elle
a gagné le concours de mini mini mini
miss et la réunion voilà c'est ça et
ensuite ça que vous avez un petit peu
vieilli quand même c'est vrai nous a vus
8 9 ans et c'est vrai que le regard des
garçons un peu changé sur vous et moi je
suis toujours resté fan de vous même et
internet est à peine 15 à 15 et
maintenant vous en avez 16 ou 17 magique
ou très bien et chez certains ouais ben
en même temps je vais pas dire ça parce
qu'en même temps dans le livre de
nicolas est un personnage qui s'appelle
louis qui drague une jeune fille qu un
onze ans et je voudrais craquer des
raccourcis entre moi et personne n'a
rien à voir à bord voilà comment on
pourrait passer à tes amours
homosexuelles regarde regarde les
embrasser
jean-edouard j'étais plus amoureux de ta
période en fait love story que ta
période comédien parce qu'en fait qu'il
représente pour moi la preuve que
n'importe qui peut s'incruster sur un
plateau télé et tenter de devenir une
star comme ça en trois minutes et c'est
vrai que j'avais trouvé une quinzaine de
cartes de bons clients par terre sur le
trottoir disent que je les amène est-ce
que je n'amène pas et finalement le plus
simple pour venir c'était de devenir
copains avec nicolas rey qu'est ce que
tu dirais d'une pause bisou à kita
permettrait d'en brasser à la fois à
séverine ferrer est à la fois louis
comme disait le commandant je crois qu
on touche le fond
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
bonsoir
[Musique]
les jeunes
voilà donc après 7 pouces d'un soupçon
se sent plus proche les uns des autres
on a partagé un moment ensemble on s'est
touché on s'est rapprochés on a envie de
jeter l'ancré
il faut mouiller avec des morues il est
génial c'est jean-michel vraiment et
baffie fais gaffe il a expliqué ton
boulot tu t'y connais en poisson mais il
fait des bonnes vannes jean-michel
semaine sur deux d'accord moi je râle
encore des points sky et indicateurs
d'évaluation notre bateau là moi je
reste ici c'est super je suis bien là
donc louis non pilule bon vous lui avez
déclaré votre amour vous l'avait
embrassée nous pour rester là vous êtes
bien enfin de sa sortie larve n'étaient
pas tous
bah oui il a l'esprit et tout c'est
juste là non mais quand on aime quand on
aime on a plus d'esprit assez ça quand
on aimerait un peu con comme disait joey
starr sacre et in iz l'amour non c'est
béatrice dalle qui disait en parlant de
joris père alors jean edouard oui le pic
jésus là et ça parle de quoi
jésus l'accueil c'est l'histoire en fait
un peu du milieu de la prostitution dans
les années 20 à montmartre à travers
l'idée d'un jeune prostitué homosexuel
c'est son amour qu'il a envers une
prostituée d'un certain âge ans qui
retrouve un peu un côté maternel et qui
est marie laforêt tout à fait voilà et
voilà l'histoire se passe à montmartre
dans le milieu des démarches loup
effectivement leur départ marie laforêt
assez mal réagi elle vous appelle vous
dis mais enfin il faut pas qu'on fasse
cette pièce ensemble enfin tu n'es pas
comédien avant elle m'appelait pour ça
elle t'a appelé pour ça oui même si
c'est la seule fois où elle m'a appelé
c'était pour me dire écoute je suis
derrière toi quoi qu'on puisse dire
c'est pas parce que tu es né de la real
tv qu'on n'y arrivera pas moi je trouve
qu'il se trouve super donc apparemment
les attaques un premier coup de fil où
elle s'inquiétait en disant il veut le
faire peut-être quelqu'un d'autre mais
en tout cas c'est comme avant c'est pas
toi non c'est pas moi non parce que moi
la version que j'ai c'est quelqu'un paie
d'une première fois en te disant c'est
un coup de fric bon voilà et qu'après
ltte rappel en disant banon ont
finalement quand elle a vu ta première
réplique elle a dit tu joues bien y'a
pas de problème
le premier coup de téléphone je n'ai pas
eu elle s'est trompée
bah oui elle s'est trompée le problème
c'est qu'à cause du loft été obligés
d'être excellent parce que c'est vrai
que ça c'est terrible on ne pardonnera
rien tu comprends pourquoi on te trouve
bon il faut que tu sois excellent jaurès
g et tu le sais bah ouais non parce que
le décès mais en même temps je le prend
plutôt bien c'est plutôt logique parce
qu'on a commencé à être connu avant
d'avoir fait quelque chose donc
logiquement canton
les choses vont un peu plus vite donc si
on est moyen bon et mauvais si on est
bon les moyens est très bon on est moins
correct voit donc on essaye d'être très
bon coin
il faut que tu sois très bon bah ouais
je fais un peu tout cas je fais tout
pour alors tu dis j'en ai assez que l'on
pense que je n'ai rien dans la tête j'ai
quand même fait un an de droit et j'ai
un bts d'action commerciale d'antigel la
question n'est pas cool pourquoi mais
celui-ci une déclaration qu'il a fait
lui non c'est pas c'est pas le fait
d'avoir fait les études qui me rendrait
plus intelligents mais c'est le fait que
la télévision parfois rend les gens un
peu plus con c'est à dire que vis-à-vis
du public bas on enferme dans une image
ou untel est méchant
et pas uniquement pour les gens de la
télé réalité pour tout le monde intel
est méchant et ça va même jusque chez
les comédiens ou quand un comédien qui
joue tout le temps les rôles des bandits
vont finir par dire que c'en est un donc
c'est un moment où on a envie de
remettre les choses à leur place et
d'expliquer aux gens que c'est pas parce
que on a c'est une émission de télé
réalité qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
et qu' une certaine image et de vous a
été accentuée que obligatoirement
alsacien temps de paddy des études on a
juste dit un bts d'action commerciale
ce qui est terrible c'est que les gens
de la télé réalité ils ont du mal parce
qu'ils sont devenus célèbres avant
d'avoir fait quelque chose donc après il
faut nourrir cette notoriété c'est très
compliqué donc toi tu en es là et puis
surtout toi tu es devenu célèbre dans
cette scène bondues du loft avec loana
donc c'est vrai que d'un seul coup ça va
être difficile de faire oublier cette
consolidation dans la piscine le
problème des gens de latéralité pour
certains c'est nourrir la notoriété et
moi mon show n'était pas de nourrir la
notoriété mais de véritablement faire un
travail de fond et sur le long terme
donc c'est pour ça que depuis un certain
temps je me fais discret je me plains
pas non plus que tous les gens viennent
me voir pour revenir sur un plateau
parce que je pense que de temps en temps
vous me fermer sa gueule que parler pour
rien dire alors vous dites jean-edouard
avec loana nous n'avions pas conscience
de tourner un film porno notre contrat
stipulait qu'aucune scène de sexe ne
serait diffusé c'est vrai ça tout à fait
où est dans le contrat et est bien
stipulé que justement tout ce qui
pouvait toucher à la sexualité ne serait
pas diffusé donc bah moi je fais or
ajoute heures jeudi soir sous l'eau au
pouliguen signé ici
non jamais
quelque chose que je pense beaucoup
d'autres auraient fait et sans se
soucier que les camions puissent filmer
parce que pour nous elle fonctionnerait
pas à ce moment là donc on a fait puis
voix est ce qui a été fait a été fait on
a su à ce qu'on vous a reproché c'est
pas ça parce que ça à la limite
effectivement tout le monde aurait été
ravi de le faire et qui est censé passer
jal moi ce que j'avais sous l'eau il a
changé de sexe
les palois jean michel non
[Applaudissements]
jojo bonjour mon nom mais ce qu'on vous
a reproché quand même c'est d'avoir
laissé tomber quoi c'est ça qui a quand
même handicapé vos chances de gagner
c'est que voilà on met quoi à loana je
sais pas moi ça s'est fait d'un
consentement mutuel et au départ oui
mais après je veux dire vous que vous
dites
bon on avait tous les deux envie de
tirer un coup puis le lendemain elle est
venue me voir en disant qu'elle était
amoureuse qu'elle voulait se marier
bah ouais mais ça vous paraît pas
bizarre justement que les filles
puissent venir vous voir et vous dire
j'ai envie de me marier avec toi le
lendemain un truc pareil
bah ouais c'est moche quand elle
s'accroche ou dans une telle situation
donc c'est logique que je réagisse comme
ça je pense que beaucoup de monde aurait
réagi de la même façon sans vouloir
faire de pub on est dans courir à 30 ans
la 17 euros au diable vauvert
mais rien
vraiment c'est ça la lâcheté enfin j'en
parle énormément d'encourir en temps
c'est ça c'est qu'est ce que c'est que
le guide de survie de nos joueurs du mal
de vivre masculin c'est aussi la lâcheté
comme la dépression comme l'ironie comme
donner c'est ça et c'est pas grave il ay
là il était dans l'instant quoi dans
l'instant la peau saine a eu ce matin
vient le voir elle lui dit cham hausse
de toi pourquoi on se marie pas lui par
en cours - d'aller vers ça n'intéressait
pas donc en même temps j'ai été honnête
elle ait besoin de la lâcheté que de
dire le ballon ça m'intéresse pas
d'aller plus haut alors ensuite j'ai
fait une petite romance avec jennifer de
la star ac c'est vrai c'était
d'encaisser limbert dans là c'est l'un
des rares à celle inverse c'est à dire
que là vous avez complètement craqué un
jean et doivent l'être en vous dévoilant
ce qu'il faut jamais faire grand père
nicolas qui est un spécialiste de l'âme
humaine vous le dira mieux que moi mais
c'est vrai il a écrit une lettre en se
dévoilant une lettre d'amour
elle lui a reproché son manque de
maturité tu vois ah ouais non je sais
pas s'ils n'ont peut-être pas peut-être
est-ce que à ce que donnait est ce que
quand on est moi je suis je suis le
genre de garçon qui quand je suis
amoureux jeudi tout tout de suite
pour beaucoup de gens c'est souvent un
manque de maturité que pour beaucoup de
gens il faut maintenant il faut aller
il voit une certaine n'a pas fait si ça
paiera logique non moi j'ai pas fait de
cinéma comme j'aurais voilà comme je dis
à l'onas intéresse pas d'aller plus loin
belge j'ai dit voilà ce que je pense je
vais dit ça m'intéresse d'aller plus
loin et quand j'aime quelqu'un je lui
dis je lui cache pas quoi donc ces êtres
c'est très mature je pense pas ça être
honnête et dévoiler ses sentiments je
pense que c'est la meilleure des choses
à faire il est bien ce genre edwards
mais l'agent edwards a raison il faut
passer en sept ans pour tomber amoureux
des gens parfois voilà il dit et tu es
tombé amoureux de jennifer vraiment tu
l'a écrit une lettre s'est passée la
déception
non pas du tout non c'était une aile
parce qu'un soir je les avais un soir
elle était en droit et elle m'a dit j'ai
envie de te voir et donc j'ai fait le
déplacement qui était quand même un long
trajet et je suis resté juste une nuit
lendemain j'ai laissé une lettre avec
comme dans le nid dans ce que je pensais
enfin voila j'ai enfin ça venait du
coeur et après la fait souffrir à lui a
posé des lapins ils ont échangé des
propos aigres-doux enfin ça s'est mal
terminée est ce que c'est parce que vous
avez souffert jean-edouard bas je pense
que quand on aime quelqu'un et que ça se
passe comme ça ouais on en souffre au
minimum donc ne fait pas trop souffrir
louis quand même mais c'est encore oui
ça va être intégralement érotisme depuis
jennifer ya rien n'en est rien il n'y a
rien eu depuis jennifer faye et d'autres
filles mais pas de l'aventuré mode
aventure amoureuse non juste mais la wii
là vous êtes concentré sur la pièce et
ouais ouais enfin c'est plutôt ça cette
aventure c'est le travail sur la pièce
sur quelle pièce jésus lacaille de carco
adapté par frédéric dard à l'espace
cardin à partir du 16 avril
voilà là vous vous concentrez sur marie
laforêt je me concentre sur la pièce et
sur l'ensemble des comédiens qui jouent
avec moi parce qu'une pièce je pense
qu'avant tout c'est une troupe ce n'est
pas juste un premier rôle est donc ça
c'est partager enfin y'a pas une pièce
avec un acteur il ya une pièce avec une
troupe est donc ce soit le dernier
dernier commet le dernier rôle
le second rôle où le premier rôle je
pense qu'ils aient chacun a son
importance il a pris tous les tics des
comédiens des acquéreurs dit il
c'est là menteur mais j'ai souvent
entendu des gens en faire le reproche
justement certains comédiens de ne
parler que d'eux quand ils font la promo
d'une pièce de théâtre mais je pense
qu'une pièce de théâtre avant tout c'est
pas un comédien c'est une troupe est une
pièce de théâtre et c'est pas un seul
comédien sur scène qui va faire tout
maraîchers les fruits de mer c'est
normal de citer tout le plateau
oui
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai j'aurais de voir que
vous êtes interdite de piscine nord plus
de 30 départements
j'étais pas au courant mais je vous le
dis même temps j'ai pas fallait prendre
dès avant c'était moi danser ni la
piscine
jean et loire vous avez refusé de
participer à cette cette chanson ouais
des lofteurs way up and down
pourquoi parce que l'époque bas à vendre
parce que moi j'avais commencé le
théâtre j'avais 8 ans et donc mais pour
permettre de gagner ma vie à côté de mes
études j'ai été jetée dj est bon ou
mauvais quand je suis sortie du loft et
que j'ai voulu continuer là dedans en
attendant pour payer mais mes cours de
théâtre
j'ai dit bas
même ce sera difficile j'ai envie de me
faire à une crédibilité dans le milieu
de la musique électronique et j'ai
estimé que c'était pas en faisant un tel
titre que j'y arriverai voilà donc j'ai
préféré dire non alors que je suis sûr
que les gens sont incapables de les gens
pensent que que vous si les faits mais
moi l'intérieur de savoir que les pas
fait j'en suis d'autant leur faisait
refusé à peine dame ne vous n'échapperez
pas jean-edouard à une interview
happened
[Musique]
attention ce que vous préférez en vous
mon coeur ce que vous détestez en vous
on est tombé j'ai l'impression d'avoir
une bouteille à la place du génial j'ai
l'impression d'avoir sauvagement bien
tourner séverine tu n'aimes pas sonné
j'ai l'impression d'avoir une série de
squales et des yeux d'algues jaunes m6
maaf flotte au gré des mois jean-edouard
ce que vous préférez dans le théâtre les
trois courts la troupe
ouais le partage entre les comédiens les
émotions qu'on se donne et qu'on reçoit
ce que vous n'aimez pas du tout le
théâtre les tensions parce que j'ai
l'impression que malgré tout chacun ses
petites habitudes et très vivant et bas
chacun ne veux pas en changer et donc le
tout c'était parfois de ça va prendre
sur soi ou de savoir dire les choses
clairement
le plus grand moment de votre vie le
sort de la générale le pire moment doit
trouver le jour où mes deux grands
parents ont disparu et le domaine santé
en l'occurrence pendant que ce qui vous
plaît le plus dans la vie
l'ambition le fait de savoir de vouloir
mettre tout ce qu'on a en soi pour pour
arriver à quelque chose qu'on s'est
fixés ce qui nous fait vraiment chier
dans la vie hypocrisie et tête de con
votre plus gros coup de fric plus gros
coup de fric
honnêtement alors là je crois que j'en
ai pas fait parce que toutes les fois où
on m'a proposé justement surtout après
le loft parce qu'avant j'étais m'a
proposé 201 pas mal de choses et mon
plus gros coup de fric c'est d'avoir
refusé de faire lofteurs open homme qui
avait rapporté chacun comme un gros
paquet de fric peu plus grosse perte
mes grands parents ouais l'autre plus
belle histoire d'amour
une jeune fille à l'époque où je
travaillais donc dans une discothèque
avec ce en provence avec qui je
travaillais j'étais tombé
follement amoureux d'elle et pareil
j'étais prêt à tout pour y arriver et
j'y suis pas arrivé le plus minable
histoire d'amour celle là aussi ouais
bah j'en ai avec 2 et les deux ont foiré
donc choisir faut trancher est-ce que
vous avez des plus sexy je sais pas mais
main même si n'importe quoi je sais pas
d'un très beau cul quand même c'est du
climat est-ce que vous avez deux mois
sexy mon nez le prouve mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a avec son avocat c'est une
obsession
louis lui et quelques jeunes est un très
joli nez jean edouard vous préférez dans
le sexe la levrette ce qui me dégoûte
dans le sexe ça existe la chevrette
qu'est-ce qui me d'ebit de retraite j'ai
passé six heures karting
des gouttes dans le sexe c'est certain
côté malsain qui peuvent être poussé
très loin
oui j'irai pas tu aimes pas le sexe mâle
ça tout dépend ce qu'on appelle massin
pour les gens une fellation ce peut être
malsain et pour d'autres coucher avec un
cheval c'est très malsain ouais ça
dépend quel chemin jean edouard lipa et
marie laforêt dont jésus la cale à
l'espace cardin
tu à partir du
[Musique]
bon ben oui on va vous vire assez normal
prochaine thierry prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
[Musique]
oh
m
si victoria et david beckham
[Musique]
non
bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle surtout cette semaine les
tabloïds anglais parle de la crise au
sein de votre couple
quelle salle ar on pourrait dire ça ils
ont écrit que david victoria vous aurait
trompé avec une ancienne jeune et jolie
assistante nommé rebecca luz qui a 25
ans savait ça c'est vraiment de
complètement absurde ce temps raconte
plein de trucs sur nous dans la presse
et c'est presque jamais vrai fabrication
ouais enfin elle dit quand même qu'à
l'époque où victoria était à beckingham
palace à londres avec les enfants
là une aventure sexuelle avec vous à
madrid ce que je peux dire c'est que
c'est juste presse à sensation c'est pas
vrai en fait on dit aussi que victoria
chante bien c'est toi et ouais beaucoup
de
alors les messages sur votre portable
publié par la presse et vendue par cette
rebecca luz 500 mille dollars sont assez
chaud quand même ça aussi vous savez il
ya des gens qui en profitent surtout
dans la presse
on est connu et victoria et moi et mes
tout ça ça va ça va être étouffé toute
façon toute façon on s'adore oui oui
vous avez déclaré david suite à ça je
suis marié et heureux ça suffit vous
pensé pour pour étouffer le scandale
bien sûr bien sûr l'amour est plus fort
que jamais entre nous et si on arrive à
surmonter ça ça nous rendra encore plus
fort ouais c'est ce que les victoria
elle dit nous avons traversé des choses
pires notre couple va survivre à ça
absolument
on s'adore et on est vraiment comme des
meilleurs amis au final quel sens y a
pas de confiance dans une relation il ya
vraiment rien et cette confiance à
l'existant trn ou alors c'est difficile
victoria de garder l'homme le plus sexy
de la planète
j'ai mes moyens de le garder c'est ma
cuisine qui le retient alors au japon
les fans achètent des morceaux des draps
ou david beckham a dormi
est ce qu a madrid on achète aussi les
morceaux draw vous avez dormi avec
rebecca de david mais y'a rien à acheter
est ce que don est ce que dans le public
j'ai des questions à poser à victoria
session vous venez monsieur tient melvin
va vous bien en dix mois
est ce que tu as des questions à poser à
david ou victoria beckham
j'aimerais savoir comment des vies de
vie sont à l'eau j'appelle des eaux là
à savoir comment david avis on vit en ce
moment c'est année à madrid
you live et balistiques a dressé un
parent je me suis vraiment installer la
enfin non pas les critiques plutôt des
critiques saleh on s'est bien débrouillé
le début de la saison ça se passe bien
vers la fin un peu moins bien mais
mais voilà je me sens bien j'adore jouer
dans cette équipe
et plein de joueur que j'adore donc
c'est vraiment un rêve qui est devenu
une réalité qui en tirer qu'est ce que
tu as fais des manches toi et monaco
notamment traducteur qui le fait de
faire vas-y non je jouais pas je
souhaite pas d'ailleurs
ouais l'équipe a perdu 8 hi lo monaco
alors c'est sûrement une bonne équipe
vaincue merci est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
gens venaient mademoiselle profitez-en
c'est 40 euros je voudrais poser la
question victoria savoir si l arrêter
complètement sa carrière de chanteuse
aussi tout toile var continuer encore ou
si elle va sortir un prochain album
qu'est ce que j'avais prévu en fait
c'était de sortir un album tout bientôt
mais j'ai aussi mes enfants je passais
du temps avec ma famille je m'occupais
de ça pour l'instant c'est un peu mon
programme donc je sortirai un disque
dans quelques temps sur melandri très
bien vous mais moi je vais vraiment
savoir si c'était vraiment les beckham
ce soir
et dédé calme trafic et kerry s
construire le vos lunettes et un diamant
mais ses yeux officiel de beckham
alors est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est vrai on dit que vous n'avez pas le
droit de croiser david beckham que c'est
interdit
à vrai dire moi je les ai rencontrés
plusieurs fois d'ailleurs j'ai été sa
doublure dans une pub et quand david
arrive c'est vrai qu'il faut que je
quitte le plateau il dit qu'il veut pas
me rencontrer
il trouve que c'est bizarre hein et vous
vous avez le droit de croiser victoria
beckham j'ai fait du doublage je
pourrais la hausse atteint film est
effectivement quand je les rencontre
elle était très sympa ça n'a pas l'air
de la déranger particulièrement que je
sois là on a parlé elle est vraiment
sympa c'est vrai que vous avez croisé à
la gare victoria est ce que vous avez eu
en dit des menaces de mort déjà de gens
qui vous reprochez de de jouer le sosie
de david beckham
ça fait six ans qu'on fait ça maintenant
c'est un boulot à plein temps pour nous
et au tout début quand on a commencé des
vies tout le monde le détester parce
qu'il avait été
mais planté avec l'argentine et et c'est
vrai qu'on a eu des menaces de mort
quotidiennement on a même mis le feu à
ma voiture
c'était horrible comme un vrai cauchemar
ouais bon on y recrute est de plus en
plus maintenant c'est encore plus un
boulot à plein temps donc c'est bien
c'est bien votre joueur préféré c'est
qui votre jour de foot préférée c'est un
zidane
alors est-ce que camilla est ce que vous
chantez aussi mal que victoria a bien
fait non moi je me contente de chanter
sous la douche je vous avez été reçu par
le le sosie de la reine d'angleterre
on a rencontré le sosie vous êtes
ensemble tous les deux meilleures amies
beaucoup j'ai pas ensemble vous n'êtes
pas ensemble dans la vie tous les deux
camilla ayant dit non mais on est
vraiment des super amis vous avez coché
en commun moi ça marche pas comme ça
chez moi
du coup de tangage on appelle ça le
french kiss baiser française et nous ça
se fait pas en un an alors que la langue
et vous connaissez la causerie zhu vous
connaissez ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci des émeutes
d
beaucoup d'ailleurs cabinda live
combat et maintenant voici dolores
chaplin
[Musique]
malheureusement soir donc appelé le fils
du commandant cousteau la petite fille
de charlie chaplin
décidément ce soir ça va avec la fille
de michael chaplin voilà et de patricia
votre maman originaire de trinitad vous
connaissez ni pleurer non maintenant que
l'art est bien lecteurs aviv qui
s'appelle courir à 30 ans mais ça car le
pitch bah oui il va faire le film et
maintenant on déconne c'est pour rire
parce que parfois de le reste ça vous
arrive d'être moralement dans un état
second voire tertiaire de pas avoir trop
le moral quoi oui oui alors les et
couvrira 30 ans oui je vais le lire
j'ai regardé en coulisse 17 euros au
diable vauvert ce qui n'est rien qu'est
ce que tu es qu'est ce que c'est que ces
clés de nos rêves c'est quoi ça déménage
mais je sais pas je me suis retrouvé que
les clés dans la main et je me demandais
pourquoi on avait fait un club on verra
donc il ya rien d'essentiel dans cette
lancée pour pouvoir l'ouvrir après vous
avez rien laissé d'extraordinaire son
sac peut-être oui avec son mec peut-être
oui un passé ouais ça va oui bon je
m'arrête vos parents la sûreté des
cartes de crédit est à présent une carte
de bons clients
laurent blanc je le ferai
il vient de mon père jean edouard oui
mon ami et mon ami le mont apporte avant
je veux en donner une à jean-michel pour
des raisons halieutiques
voilà la mairie non ma fille tu lui dis
qu'elle est mignonne
alors cette carte là je vous l'avais pas
100 euros jusqu'à 50 euros donnés mais
simplement 30 euros louis les nerfs à
lui l'anr pour 10 euros 30 euros 30
euros
oui vous 30 euros bouly 40 euros 60
euros 100 euros fait gaffe braqueurs
vraiment car millénaire 10 euros on vend
les cartes de bons clients c'est une
aura et jean-edouard tu peux lire pour
l'association la botte tiamat je lui
donne ensuite moi j'aime responsabilité
d'une comptabilité a fondu est un joueur
de bon coeur
[Applaudissements]
faut dire que j'ai vu ce qu'il a fait à
l'eau un art le temps ne reste que si
c'est une tradition tout le monde
s'embrasse
oui quelque chose de très mal à
embrasser avec beaucoup de ces données
pendant une demi seconde la grl et thé
chaud comme la braise jaloux vient donc
en parler des parents de leurs aises
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est vrai vous êtes
jaloux on a une autre alors même et tu
t'es pas donner ton mari de ton fils est
au plus bas
non mais faut voir aussi dans l'arrêté
marrari ton fils de ton accouchement
s'est passé après
jean-edouard je dois de séverine sois
gentil mais depuis tout à l'heure je
m'en occupais c'est bien donc je vais
essayer quand même de raconter un petit
peu la vie de dolores donc votre père
c'est michael chaplin votre mère c'est
patricia originaire de trinidad parents
un peu baba cool hein faut le dire parce
que votre père par réaction contre son
père de charlie chaplin a été un petit
peu comme ça rebelles
vous savez ce que c'est jean-michel
j'aimais millénaire qui est un charlot
donc un renfort vagabonde en france en
espagne en irlande à trinidad et un jour
vous et votre famille finissait par
atterrir dans le sud-ouest de la france
dans une ferme en ruine où vous vous
nourrissez tous des produits du potager
et du lait des chèvres
quel est votre père parce que votre père
est un éleveur de chèvres alors
évidemment à l'école personne ne veut
croire que de leur s est la fille de
michael chaplin les petites filles de
charlie chaplin parce que bon on s'en
faire une caisse un peu pour ave qu'il
avait échangé contre deux chèvres c'est
vrai c'est vrai voilà c'est tout est-ce
que c'était une deux chevaux
non c'est pas drôle il y avait plein de
stickers parce que ça devait appartenir
à deux jeunes gens un truc comme ça
vraiment elle qui trouve un phénomène
son plein il faudra attendre la mort de
votre grand-mère una pour que vous
alliez vivre au bord du lac léman qui
s'embrassent maison de charlie chaplin
voilà alors avant vous alliez dans cette
maison uniquement pour l'épauler
vacances et vous avez pas tu es mon
toubib en fait de charlie chaplin à un
vieux monsieur qui ont poussé dans un
dans un fauteuil roulant quoi voilà est
ce que vous faisiez le lien entre lui à
l'époque et le personnage en noir et
blanc des films muets n'ont jamais parce
que je sais pas si c'est très séparés
à tel point que mon petit frère à un
moment donné penser que louis de funès
était de notre grand père il dit c'est
monsieur très drôle c'est mon grand père
c'est ça il comprend des très petites
très jeunes de l'aurès vous commencé à
monter des spectacles payants pour vos
parents et à quel âge 7 8 ans et
restrictif et à quel âge 12 ans je sais
pas si c'est légal justement des
strip-teases à 12 ans absolument pour
vos parents n'ont parents et leurs amis
parents c'est sympa de faire dans le sud
ouest 1 voilà enfin en tous les cas vous
vous commencé à rentrer comme ça dans le
monde du spectacle est aujourd'hui à une
chanson qui a énormément de succès qui
est une chanson on entend la voix de
votre votre grand père et qui s'appelle
modern times c'est à dire les temps
modernes
[Musique]
g
il faut dire c'est que c'est un morceau
qui a été remixé bien entendu mais
autour de la voix de votre grand-père
mais non c'est très très mignon j'ai
trouvé ça m'a tout de suite plu r je
trouve une anecdote très marrante ce qui
des femmes qui écrivent à g-five qui
demandent des posters de charlot ouais
c'est très très vite et mixeur qui a
refait sa dj choléra part ça fait
connaître vraiment à une autre
génération
je me rends compte qu'il y avait
vraiment une génération qui connaît pas
trop enfin que tu connais pas du tout en
fait tu connais ça ouais
[Musique]
alors le clip de ce morceau reprend des
images de l'avant première du film à new
york en 1936 il a été réalisé par
raphaël frydman qu'un super metteur en
scène et c'était c'était comme un mini
film c'était non c'est être vous voulez
qu'on le voit là oui pourquoi vous
regardez votre caméra là wide rouge
voilà
et vous dites magnéto serge magnéto
serge très bien moi
[Applaudissements]
chacun doit avoir le temps on
m
sinon
gd
m
[Musique]
taipei tuerie de la chaplin john tague
c'est à dire les temps modernes voilà
alors est ce que vous savez que votre
grand père a participé à un concours de
sosies de charlie chaplin et qu'il a été
recalé non c'est vrai c'est historique
vous saviez pas ça il a été recalé
recaler un concours de sosies de charlie
chaplin c'est énorme c'est génial je
venais ici je vous dirais détruits on
sait que je viens bien alors
ben vous serez pas étonné que je fasse
une interview cinéma muet
donc je ne veux rien entendre mais
entendu enlevé dans le cinéma muet de
leur s dont vous me regardez et vous
allez me faire la tête que vous faites
quand on vous pose sans arrêt les mêmes
questions sur votre grand-père - est pas
mal mais la tête que vous faites quand
on rit pas devant les films de votre
grand-père quand on vous reproche les
charlots la tête que font les gens chez
eux quand ils regardent c'est une seule
[Rires]
la tête que vous faites quand on vous
dit que vous êtes ravissante questions
pense qu'il faut c'est bon la tête que
vous faites quand on vous dit tu fais
quoi après l'émission de la rai la tête
que vous faites quand on vous dit je
t'aime c'est par la lèvre pardon
jean-michel
dolores regardez-moi la tête que vous
faites quand on vous propose de passer à
l'acte on avait elle parle pas le
français
la tête que vous faites quand vous
trouvez que l'animateur est lourd
ouais la tête que vous faites quand vous
pardonner à l'animateur d'être lourd
ouais la tête que vous faites quand
c'est la fin notre interview et la tête
qu'elle fait quand elle dit je t'aime à
quelqu'un ouais elle dit je t'aime à
quelqu'un la tête que vous faites dit je
t'aime actuellement quant à nicolas
laulan nicolas nicolas
elle me fait super bien
achat là que le prince
g
[Musique]
voici basket
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pascal simon
[Applaudissements]
oui vous n'avez que des copains avoir
des amis ici pascal sellem à commencer
par arrête toi même tu es bien là tuner
jean-michel voilà les oreilles ya un
copain ça va ça va super bien
alors vous bossez pascal sellem à tf1
sur les sept péchés capitaux
est-ce que c'est par envie ou par
paresse les deux bravo non c'est la
première qu'un genevois était déjà en
plus pendant les sept péchés capitaux
vous faites des caméras cachées voulait
qu'on cache les caméras là vous sentirez
plus à l'aise non non ça va s'ajouter la
famille si ça vous dérange pas alors
pascal vous sortez les caméras cachées
que vous avez réalisé pour les sept
péchés capitaux
alors pour en vendre 1 million vous
savez ce qu'il faut faire la promo ouais
y avait pas de parti pris c'est un
bonheur vous regardez votre caméra et
vous dites magnéto serge serge manitou
way commente à la grosse tête
magnéto serge papin
au delà qui nous a accueillis moi je te
fasse curatteau oui la pizza non pas la
piste la pizza et si tu la prends je les
vends les victimes qui est fou contient
un fanta pitt
[Musique]
à
allez soit sympa attend enfin pitt je
dois fais pas tu veux une [ __ ] je te
refais ma fais moi une fleur fraîche
fraîche ouais je sais pas j'ai pas
d'argent tu peux te les changes voilà
qui change c'est là les restos du coeur
ici aux cours actuels ta pizza tu fais
qu'un tapis tu es tu veux toi aussi tu
vas du mans l'huile piquante peut
prendre la table ouais c
qui fait je te demande et on m'a dit oui
parce qu'elle commence activa
d'apprendre ou d'aller faire de quoi
vous allez oust avec la table mais vous
me dites shuttle plein de la table ah
non mais sérieux repose toi parce que
j'ai pas envie de rigoler aujourd'hui
c'est un mauvais jour mais moi je
croyais que vous prendrez la table pour
nous at war
d'accord c'est pas prendre au cp1 moi je
peux prendre la chose quand même à
l'achat est bien sûr d'accord merci
non non non non foot suite la pizza
occupe toi et tes garage alors je
peuvent pas parce qu'il ya du chorizo
s'appliquant mais je m'en fous et les
gars
quoi otegi eux on se calme on sait
voulait que je sorte le carnet de
timbres amendes dans pas longtemps ça va
ça va secouer encore plus je me rhabille
je vous bougez votre véhicule je peux la
finir
maroc la finir on pouvait finir quoi
aggraver sa part les wii vous rhabiller
immédiatement dans sa b2 verbalisme
d'accord parce qu'elle sait les caméras
cachées
péchés capitaux
non non non non non alors hier une
caméra cachée finalement bon d'abord on
veut trouver l'idée ensuite faut tourner
le truc et tout mais le plus compliqué
après c'est demander les autorisations
aux gens dont c'est pour ça qu'un acquis
sont floutés c'est oui il y en a
certains qu'on flottille a certains
qu'on peut pas du tout m et qu'on a bien
on aime bien les maîtres est-ce que vous
avez un exemple de caméras cachées
génial je n'ai pas pu diffuser parce que
le mec vous a pas donné l'autorisation
de diffusion non non non parce que le
mec le mec on a envie qu'il passe dans
ta caméra cachée tu es obligé tu restes
avec lui jusqu'à ce qu'il signe
pendant deux heures tulasne jusqu à ce
qu ici qu'est ce que tu racontes pour
qu'il signe que tu fais c'est un autre
métier c'est ces bonimenteurs quand tu
baratine marathi et si tu préfères c'est
quoi le
le pitch de la caméra cachée que tu
préfères de toutes celles que tu as fait
toutes celles que j'ai fait je crois que
c'est celle que j'ai faite en père noël
un où les enfants venaient faire il
existait pas le père noël tu vois les
enfants venaient prendre la photo avec
le père noël et au fur et à mesure on a
mené les enfants dans la classe et quand
quand il arrivait je dormais et d'un là
les enfants leur soit les enfants nous
réveillait quelque en soit il piquait
les bons bords lesquels d'horreur il
était déçu les mauves non non non
c'était très très mignon aja les
histoires comme je sors le pote bien
pascal riu travailler à tf1 ouais mais
pas que ça serait aussi comédiens durant
deux d'abord écoute on va te faire une
interview
quand on bosse à tf1
[Musique]
et après cette interview tu ne seras
plus parce qu'elle s'est même quand on
bosse et tf1 est ce qu'on le dit à sa
famille à ses amis ses enfants non je
leur cash
on leur dit je suis désolée je suis bien
obligé de vivre des trucs comme ça je
leur dis que c'est grâce à tf1 qui sont
en train de manger de la viande abattue
et ont dit à ses enfants tu sais papa
est en train de réaliser son rêve quand
on bosse à tf1 non seulement ses enfants
depuis qu'il est rentré
est-ce qu'à la cantine ans préfère
s'asseoir entre bataille et fontaine ou
ppda avec claire chazal canton d'axât
tf1 mais si jamais foutu les pieds à tf1
ah c'était bravo c'est vrai je suis
jamais allé dans l'immeuble psychique
suis allé une fois mais ils m'ont
demandé ma carte d'identité pour rentrer
du coup je suis pas je suis pas allé
tiens encore une carte quand on bosse à
tf1 on a droit de regarder d'autres
chaînes pendant son temps libre
bien sûr si on regarde tout le temps
d'autres chaînes pendant mon tel pascal
sérieusement quand on bosse et tf1 est
ce qu'on est obligé de faire des
émissions avec carole rousseau
c'est pas moi c'est laurent qui me rend
très nerveux on est obligé de téléphoner
sur bouygues telecom non non est-ce que
des fois quand on bosse et tf1 on
aimerait aller plus loin on aimerait
aller ailleurs
on a toujours envie d'aller ailleurs
quelle belle réplique par exemple
j'aimerais bien aller ailleurs aux
toilettes par exemple quand on bosse 202
maroc c'était pas bon quand on veut cet
effort mois est ce qu'on prend un bon
paquet de thunes pascal
maintenant oui et avant ce qui est plus
dur mais maintenant oui et on laisse ses
enfants regarder way to tout c'est bien
je crois qu'il faut lui donner une carte
des secours je suis furieux parce que
c'est un poisson clown
non
absolument ça m'a pris deux heures et
demie pour avoir une carte non même
temps j'étais sous le choc de deux
heures il fait du sacré bon bon travail
12h30 pour avoir une carte à 37 secondes
et affinage en tout cas ça lui même en
dvd il est bien il ya plein plein plein
de bonus
ouais y'a les nice people que il a fait
des trucs super drôle dans son dvd il a
fait quoi
elle a fait un truc super drôle non on
paie déjà des pôles bien ouais je crois
qu'on peut donner le scoop est là c'est
une blague au jeu parce que c'est en
fait ça me sert pas trop normal ne dit
pas avant je ne dis pas ça parce
qu'alors je vais le dire en fait quand
on met le dvd les sept péchés capitaux
dans son lecteur
la première image qui arrive c'est ce
dvd ne convient pas à votre lecteur 1 et
la 3 6 7 5 secondes après trois petits
points non je déconne et là il ya des
gens qui ont déjà été voir
est ce que c'est
ces capitaux ah bon papa
il a un peu
abondamment
à
[Musique]
et maintenant on passe au bundle rapide
copains
aurore leblanc
[Musique]
leblanc bonsoir un sport leblanc vient
de sortir une compilation des conran
shop selected by
or le blanc voilà on l'applaudît mon ami
bon vous connaissez le principe du blind
test c'est pas compliqué je veux
l'interprète et on peut dire d'ores et
déjà que c'est pascal sellem qui va
gagner
leblanc thèse ce soir mon ami pascal
sellem qui a fait passer pour moi s'il
ya des équipes d'abord est ce que les
équipes sont assez bien équilibré quoi
nos deux content de rester ni à we draw
la belle fille et celle m contre le
reste du monde et en tue bien là dolores
vous passez la toi tu passes la nique
aux voilà très bien laurent baffie et
pascal sellem contre le reste du monde
attention whore
[Musique]
si quelques aux curieux
les mandats si tu as déjà
bon on a entendu ce qu'il a dit pascal
non la même souffle m donc ça fait un
point pour l'équipe de laurent baffie et
pascal sellem et zéro point
pour le reste du monde quoi jean michel
je suis encore complètement ému mais
bien ce qui vient là c'est pour
jean-michel attention aux gens les
doigts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après
le reste du monde 1
c'est même ma fille 1 attention aurore
et 1
la vidéo a tué les stars de la radio les
buggles bravo pascal sellem attention
whore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
michael jackson je ne peux pas accepter
parce que c'est jérôme the wall donc ces
quatre jeunes le point des cas accepter
l'accord
[Applaudissements]
les lignes court mais parle point où on
en est à un partout dans un an
séverine forte mais bon séverine a dit
michael jackson oui mais après il avait
dit jackson fait en même temps en un an
papa de replay non ya pas de replay elle
a dit 'je michael jackson bien après
jackson five donc nu un demi point à 2
points suivants 10 places attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
oui
attend il a dit waouh ici j'ai ordonné
de george michael non c'est moi
[Musique]
alors la nuit ensemble d'honneur
ça nous fait combien mais il a 2 2 olala
s'est resserrée et serge toi cher gilles
un petit peu amoureux de leur rsa a bien
attention aux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis
donc ça fait 3 pour le reste du monde et
deux pour nos amis baffie et celle m
attention aurore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais vraiment yahia n'entend
séverine ferrer a dit toxiques mais 70
britney spears j'aimerais faire je
voulais vous dire un truc ce pascal
selene n'est pas bons joueurs dont je
dois vous prévenir avant parce qu'il
peut s'énerver et un coup de boule ses
devanciers avec le haut niveau tu as du
temps que ses hanches et les toxiques
britney spears a les plus sérieux dans
cette sombre en version or
[Musique]
bush
j'ai passé serge khalfon catherine barma
je vous écoute deux ans
[Applaudissements]
damouré
bon d'accord alors ces quatre pour le
reste du monde et deux pour les
champions du monde
attention non concentrez-vous parce que
voyez bien que là quand même si très
bagarre et nicolas attention whore
[Applaudissements]
bien bien bien bien non c'est octobre je
sais que le reste l'a pensé avant akiba
le point serge de l'aurès bien attention
aux hommes
[Musique]
rajoub été lâché par rip compliqué ya
deux interprètes
[Musique]
serge dans le reste
[Applaudissements]
alors là
c'est un petit peu c'est un petit peu
comme des élections en algérie d'une
certaine façon oui on a pas ciani
terrain est bon alors je sais ça fait 3
5 pour eux soit pour eux à la lan
attention j'adore la chanson qui vient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
bravo de l'aurès bien et ben écoute
franchement y'a rien à dire je crois que
de leurs récents taire tout le monde
voilà après c'est bientôt le chacun pour
soi mais encore une chanson par équipes
attention hein
[Musique]
à voir le magnéto sud pour nous voir le
dire ensemble
est ce que c'est possible ça tu veux
quoi la chanson magnéto juste pour nous
voir le dire ensemble avec de leur est à
dire sans s'arrêter
ils veulent se voir
[Applaudissements]
bien soit vous êtes en train de faire
torcher mais belle partie commençait ses
fils de coups et puis jean-michel dans
l'équipe ça les a bien aidés
avec votre permission je vous le laisse
ouais et je l'attends à vous préférez
sur le bateau sur bateau oui oui oui
dans les mérous c'est gagné les gagner
une discussion j'ai remplacé un
maquereau par une sirène c'est bien tu
peux te mettre la main sur nicolas
basque mais ont baissé jusqu'à moins que
tu veulent pas changer l'ambiance
nicolas non parce que maintenant c'est
la fin du par équipes
attention le chacun pour sa gueule ya
publiquement parce que la vie est
injuste mon gars
attention je veux l'interprète chacun
pour soi or
un bas rhin
je
[Musique]
m
pardon serge ouais je trouve que dolores
est génial parce que elle gagne quand on
a un peu honte de gagner comme ça vous
êtes vraiment touchante c'est magnifique
vraiment très belles à voir certains
pensèrent je ne vais pas gagner
touchante de pâques elle est belle à
voir
elle est belle à voir elle gagne 120
console et on travaille mon gardien
serge puis continuez à mélanger t'es
gentil d'accord bon alors bébé oui c'est
de l'or et je suis désolé a donc dolores
et maintenant il ya le super banco
aurore
la bombe un labo
à plus tard
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
la quel manager quel manager tué ni
violence mais vraiment sans recul et
macaroni donnerait il y est pour
beaucoup
nicolas pense que j'étais notre selon la
même part que ces passionnés moi là
dessus
bon ben alors là on est à de l'aurès
dolores là mais attends c'est fou cette
histoire
maintenant on passe au méga vocaux qui
va gagner d'après toi serge or
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc là la réponse qui a gagné serge
serge dormez bien là alors là évidemment
maintenant il ya une ultra banco et
voilà et là maintenant si tu pouvais te
laisses sais pas peut-être que non
peut-être que oui je sais pas on va voir
que tout le monde sait qu'on est ouest
quand la paille à une after bien leur a
rarement été aussi grave que ce soit et
que maintenant si tu donnes aures
remporte son 4e banco
je crois que là c'est je suis même pas
c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais lu tu
es tu as raison serre che du jamais vu
absolument et la banque avait fait
sauter la banque
elle prend notre salut a tous voila je
demande vraiment au public de ne pas
souffler à vraiment sérieusement je
demande aux autres produits faits pour
prendre taisez vous attention rang suis
prête à aller allons-y il faut y aller
le reste
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais que serge khalfon passe un
gros plan de leur d'oise
parce que ça c'est du jamais vu je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
énorme qui fait passer ce soir merci aux
aurores je rappelle que le disque d'or
de conran shop sélective à grenade
messieurs vous entendrez un morceau sur
le générique
vous aimez moi même on a vécu quelque
chose de beau la magnifique
il restera dans l'histoire de la mission
et de leur réussite de leur s et serge
va quitter sa femme c'est moche mais
c'est une autre vie qui commencera beau
serge
voilà je crois que c'était une bonne
émission c'est tout le monde en parle et
bien les armateurs
chez fayard albert dupontel le convoyeur
sortie le 14 avril séverine terre des
étoiles plein la tête si on leur répond
la coque chapelle sherin terreur et il
sort le 27 avril le single s'appelle je
me pardonne
nicolas rey j'aurai à 30 ans c'est
publié au diable vauvert
jean michel cousteau ners merci mon père
le commandant s'est évité à l'archipel
jean edouard lipa jésus lacaille avec
jean edouard lipa et marie laforêt à
l'espace pierre cardin à partir du 16
avril
les saisies vbck un endroit en meurent
et camille à chaque balle tape dolores
chaplin le single moderne
ach
les caméras cachées des sept péchés
capitaux
reporters sans frontières cuba le livre
noir
coédition reporters sans frontières et
la découverte voilà c'était du monde en
parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine merci
[Musique]
oui
yes